That was,
you looked at that.
This is the move point break.
Cupcake shirt point bake and we working.
Yeah,
it's working.
we live.
We,
I wish we could start this show off with
flavor and you're here.
What do we get kicked off of Youtube.
Craig mack died.
That's just a shout out.
I know.
I feel like we should be able to,
just as a shout out.
It is a great fucking song,
man.
It was such a good song.
Dude was only 46 what was it?
I didn't even see what he died of.
Heart attack.
Yeah.
Heart failure.
46 fuck man.
Major.
But we start off the show with a major
bummer.
Yeah.
We will get pulled by youtube.
Right?
If we did that,
we played it for sure.
We,
I'm sure for sure we won't play.
It won't play.
Let's just shout out to Craig back.
You know what you could do?
You could play like someone else who did
their version of it.
It should have been even then you'd
probably get,
there he is.
Oh,
oh biggies.
Now this is the,
this is the,
yeah,
I dunno.
With notorious lol and bless a bless.
No Shit.
Yeah,
don't,
don't put that up on youtube is it
already had been up.
Okay,
good.
Everybody's dying.
46 is so young to have a fucking heart
attack heart stuff.
That's everybody.
I guess I should have just guessed hard
shit.
Well,
especially in this day and age,
the way people eat terrible.
He wasn't,
was he that heavy of a dude?
I don't think you have to be that heavy
with dude clogged arteries.
But then there's super,
super heavy dudes that just had nothing
fun,
nothing phases them.
There's some guys that just keep on
trucking.
That's like in Chicago where I'm from.
That's everybody I know.
Oh yeah.
Nobody skinny is offensive.
Well not only that,
it gets zero degrees all day long.
So fucking four months.
Yeah,
you need the padding.
They need something he needed to sell.
You need somewhere to hide all that
sadness,
shove it underneath all this guy has
gray.
You hear bullets from the south side.
So when I got,
when I got in a little bit of shape and
I went back to Chicago,
I caught this like so much shit for that
from everybody.
You sell out Mr Hollywood.
Well you look,
you look in lane eaten,
eaten well,
we eat an avocado.
Caring about your future.
What does it say Jamie?
What are you six?
No cause of death was immediately
released hill for a while.
So that's what I saw.
I saw they didn't figure it out yet.
Oh I saw something on.
Yeah,
see that's a problem when someone,
you get a bunch of different versions of
the story.
Um,
I went down and Internet rabbit hole
last night.
Man,
this is a very disturbing one.
Do you know anything?
What's going on in Boyle Heights?
No.
Boyle Heights.
East la,
east La.
And um,
apparently the hipsters are starting to
open up our teas and old coffee shops
and art galleries there and they're not
having it.
And uh,
the gayborhood is pushing back.
It's more than that.
There's a lot of,
it's like straight
up racist.
It's anti white racism,
which is apparently co totally
acceptable.
You don't have cameras are blaring in
your face.
Uh,
we'll boil heights,
be ruined by one coffee shop.
It's not just one coffee shop.
They forced a gallery under.
Is this an older story from June's?
Yeah,
they forced a gallery out just through
constant harassment and they broke the
windows of this coffee shop and,
but what I watched last night there was
disturbing was these air quote activists
standing in front of this gallery.
It's a fucking art gallery.
And they're screaming,
get the fuck out.
Get the fuck out of our neighborhood.
Get the fuck out.
We don't want you here.
And the guy was like trying to talk to
him like,
you know,
some hipster guys like,
I'm,
I identify as a feminist,
like one of those guys identify as a
feminist,
you know,
one of those guys.
And he was like,
yes,
I'm here to support.
I'm here to support the me.
We all fuck it.
Why don't you get the fuck out?
Get the fuck out there chanting,
get the fuck out.
Get the fuck to chant,
It's a great chance to put up a sign
that says,
fuck white art,
white fuck white art.
The coffee shop,
they broke the windows here.
The coffee shop was even more fucked up
cause one of the guys is actually a
Mexican slopper.
No,
they fucked up proper.
Okay.
Right?
Yeah.
One of the guys who were in the coffee
shop,
they were calling it,
it's,
they called it like weird coffee or
something like that and neither they,
they put a sign on a calling it white
coffee and they broke the window.
But one of the guys who owns it is
Latino.
I don't know if he's Mexican,
but he's definitely,
it'd be funny to open up a spot called
white coffee.
Yeah.
White people come and people just called
white people problems.
Look,
a new generation of anti gentrification,
radicals are on the march in Los Angeles
and around the city.
This is not a diet is not an accurate
way to frame what's happening.
No,
that's crazy.
This is not anti gentrification
radicals.
These are,
these are rioters and then writing.
These people have fire in their hands or
walking on the street and they're
yelling at a bunch of racist shit and
they covered their faces up.
Look,
I get it.
I get what's going on.
Like they're,
they're afraid they're gonna lose their
neighborhood and they're afraid their
neighborhood's going to be pushed out.
The dinosaurs felt the same way.
So did so did cavemen.
Everybody feels the same way.
The world is a fucking fluid moving
thing.
You can't just save neighborhoods
forever.
It just doesn't work that way.
You can't save anything forever.
No.
I mean,
and there's nothing wrong with a God
damn gallery moving into your
neighborhood.
That's crazy.
Right?
That's right.
Right.
Like I fuck,
I see it when people do this whole thing
about like Walmart's moving into small
towns and that they lose,
they panic.
Like I get that.
I understand it's changing industry.
A dude selling fucking lattes is not
going to dynamically shape and,
and if it does,
it'll take 15 more.
Yeah,
it'll take 15 more years,
but they know it's coming.
They know what happens in these
neighborhoods.
It's like these hipsters move in first
because La real estate is so ridiculous.
It doesn't make like I was looking at
uh,
places near where Carolyn lives count
lives in Santa Monica and I was looking
places he lives above ground.
Yes,
I know,
right.
He lived in like the
sewer system or something like that.
Like one of them Ninja Turtles,
a turtle account live on the beef is
scoring system.
He lives in a very nice neighborhood.
I mean I'm not,
but I was just looking in Santa Monica
in general and a regular house,
like a regular house.
It's $2 million.
Yeah.
Bullshit house like was a fucking normal
house house.
Nothing like you be like,
you can bring a a gal back home like hey
my house,
you know,
look at the view of the city.
No,
there's none of that around $2 million.
You get a shack.
Two bed,
one and a half bath.
Yeah.
With fucking old bullshit linoleum.
Shitty sync with the ring.
Where at the fucking water.
The dirt has just stayed in those old la
La loves doing like,
uh,
in the 60s.
They love doing like a or in the 50s
maybe pink light pink and green
bathrooms.
So it was like pink tile and they leave
that and I was just looking today it's
Deco's at arc tech or just or just bad
decision making.
And I was looking at a place today just
before I came here.
Guys looking just Hollywood hills on the
other side.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's a nice,
but it's a nightmare.
All that stuff.
Can you think about,
they're like,
oh the drainage.
I went to a super rich dudes house.
How much does that one take?
A guess.
$2 million.
A little more.
2.2 well you know why?
Cause it's a Duplo they split it.
It,
it.
Those are two apartments they rent,
right?
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
That's to one side is a door or the
right and left or doors.
Is that,
yeah.
Yeah.
So what La does is they take these old
buildings,
split them like that so then they can
make twice the money.
The property is,
the property can't be worth that much.
It's just the fact that they can rent it
to two people.
That's a lot of money,
man.
Oh my God.
This is 1.5 0.5 how big is it?
A thousand square feet.
Square feet one.
That's the size of this studio,
right?
That's the size of where the mics are
inside of here.
It's pretty close.
A thousand square feet is really,
I mean,
if you're one dude living by yourself,
like maybe you got a dog.
Yeah,
but like didn't that one dude would just
rent?
He probably should,
unless he's just real simple.
Like there's those people that buy those
miniature houses.
Ever seen those tiny house,
tiny house that you want to talk about?
Warm whole shit.
I got it.
I ended that so deep,
Dude.
I was like,
what if I did dance?
What if I did tell me how shit.
It's why,
you know there's a show that I'm
addicted to.
It's called life below zero.
I watched three episodes.
What is it that people in Alaska,
I love that show.
I watched two episodes the other day in
one,
actually yesterday,
but the one I watched yesterday,
there's this dude who lives in a place
called,
I think it's called Shandell are it's
way above the Arctic circle and it's
fucking guy lives by himself and
apparently he used to be married and he
has kids somewhere.
Yeah,
his name's Glenn Glenville new or
something like shout out to Glenn Smart
too too,
which is weird.
He lives solo so low.
No one's around.
He lives in a room.
Not even half that.
That's,
that's homeboy right there.
He lives in a room,
not even half the size of this studio
and he just has a bunch of shit like
stacked in that rule.
I maybe it's like I'm exaggerating.
Maybe it's half the size.
That's his tent above the artists naked
there.
There's a song
this hog,
let's show his diesel Odis.
See,
here's the thing about these things.
Like you got to realize that on these
shows there's a lot of the stuff they do
is just bullshit.
They just do it for camera.
Like what would it be?
Good episode today.
Well,
maybe I can make my own sauna.
Yeah.
Make a song.
Like what?
He'd be really be making a sauna.
I don't know.
But what this guy does is just,
he goes out and shoots Moose and
Caribou.
Oh,
he eats almost exclusively meat.
He lives where there's fucking no
plants.
I mean there's trees grow.
You're not growing Jack Shit.
Wolves in his yard.
He had a shoot wolves once they were in
his backyard.
Yeah,
to shoot them because they were coming
for his food.
I see him training the wolf's.
He starts training heaven.
Shit.
So you don't really train wolfs he
trained those bitch ass half wolves that
become dogs.
Right.
That's they turn into,
they turn it to uh,
his,
uh,
his sauna.
Wolf's Hisana dogs.
Unless you're like beastmaster you have
like a special bracelet and you walk
through the forest and they'll follow
you.
They kind of want it to be that right.
Never.
Beastmaster you remember that show?
Fucking do like always had like a hawk
landing on his shoulder and shit.
Just go like this and a bird land on
him.
Yeah.
It didn't have like a fucking mountain
lion or something that hung around with
them too and walk with them.
Everyone's guardian.
Yeah,
like here he is.
those fair,
those ferrets are like a pigeon kite
pigeons in New York.
You know what I mean?
The parents distribute messages
throughout the forest.
Do you know ferrets were illegal in some
places for a while as to pets.
Too much anal,
but people shoving him up their ass.
I don't think that's fair.
It's they'll get them with a hawk on his
hand.
Is that an eagle looked at up.
Why do people,
why were ferreted league?
I got it.
Nobody thought they were aggressive,
which is hilarious.
And you think about how many dogs people
have that are just ridiculously faces
off and shit.
I fucking golden retriever attack my
golden retriever and bite his face when
we were on a run the other day.
What do you do?
I just pulled them apart and he yelled
at the guy who controls fucking dog and
what does he do?
The guy was so weak like he,
the dog polled and the guy comically
fell to his ass,
feet up in the air from a dog and meets
a 70 pound dog.
It's not a big dog.
Yankton right out.
He said like the dog is a problem and it
bites things and tries to bite people.
I'm like,
well you got a bad dog van.
Put a fucking muzzle on it or something
or figure it out,
but he can't even hold the dog.
Like there's people that have animals
that they're just hoping nothing goes
wrong.
They have zero control over right thing
and this thing pulled and this guy like
whoop feet went flying cartoons so weak.
And then when I separated the dogs,
he tried to pull the dog back.
He couldn't pull the dog back.
I'm like,
come on man,
like you shouldn't have this dog.
It's not even a big dog.
You should have a fucking Chihuahua
emasculating moment for a guy to like
have another man be like,
Hey,
what are you doing guys?
My control your fucking dog.
I don't want to hurt the dog,
but the dog is biting my dog.
You have to stop it in some ways to do
something in some way.
So if it takes two instincts,
instinct number one is like kick it and
knock it away.
Push it away.
Instinct number two is grab a rock and
smash this fucking thing.
It's that passion.
Fighting
that instinct.
Yeah,
because that dog is like my little
buddy.
You have to protect yours.
Yes.
Well he's a sweetie too.
Like he doesn't,
he's not grounded in anything,
any time ever.
Right.
This is just a fun,
just got attacked.
Happy dog and this dog's biting onto his
face and he's Yiping and I'm trying to
figure out what to do and this fucking
guy feed up in the air.
Whoops.
Felt that he was of no use and not.
So I have to assume this dog's not going
to do anything to me.
You know,
it's biting me.
I don't know what the fuck is wrong with
his dog and wants a bite another cause
it's not a pit bull or something like
that.
If it was a pit bull,
I would have known like,
okay,
we got to go wide berth here.
Fuck away from this ring.
I know how those things behave,
but this is just like,
why is this dog doing this?
That'll be the next,
uh,
that'll be the next like reality shows
fight,
fight.
The owner,
like,
you know,
the dog's getting a thing and then
you're like,
all right,
well me and you have to fight.
Now there's people,
there's people that have dogs that don't
even understand dogs.
They don't know that they have to be the
alpha.
They don't know that.
They don't know how to go,
hey,
cut the fucking shit.
Cause they just get a dog.
They just get a dog and they just figure
everything.
It'll figure itself out.
You know,
it was bad ass with dogs.
Who Whitney Cummings,
you know,
I just got a puppy and I called her.
She called,
gave me crazy good advice.
Suit.
She doesn't fuck around in her house.
She goes,
I walked through my dogs.
I don't walk around them.
I walked through them.
Yeah.
She goes and they don't lie on top of me
and they don't get to lick my face.
I was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
no,
she told me she gave doing that.
Let me tell you,
shout out to her.
She gave me so much great advice.
She was like,
I literally,
I was like,
hey man,
do you have a little bit of time to tell
me that?
And she,
she,
I mean like a computer.
She was like,
yeah,
dude,
don't do,
don't she like named everything
perfectly that she's like,
don't make this mistake.
Don't do this.
People do this shit all the time.
It's wrong.
She laid it out great.
And Nick now,
uh,
the puppies like almost perfectly potty
trained and I just got it.
I saved my best friends.
True adopted dogs.
Yeah.
She's one of the smartest people I know,
but the absolute,
but a puppy's an asshole.
By the way.
Puppies are assholes.
So hard to deal with man.
And waking up in the middle of the night
pissing and shitting,
wanting to piss like every two hours.
I know,
I know.
Trust me.
I was,
I blew,
I learned fast that I was like,
I was like,
it'll sleep a little bit.
When was the last time you had a dog?
Years ago.
Do you have crates to keep being
cracked?
Right?
Yeah.
You've got to keep the crate thing.
They don't mind.
That was the thing.
We think what we put in the dog or the
kids know they like it.
They like it.
Yeah.
Cause they feel like,
well even when she,
even when she shits she finds a thing
that that feels like it's covering her.
She likes to be like covered when she
shit.
I mean she's a lady first of all.
Of course she wants to,
she wants to hide her shit.
What?
Same thing when she goes in the crate.
She likes it when my shirts on top of it
cause it's like,
it feels like it's a kit,
a little cave.
He knows.
The most bizarre to me is people in New
York City who live in these little ass
apartment stacked on top of each other
and they have dogs.
Great Danes.
And like what is the fuck is this crazy?
How are you doing this?
Like you have to,
that is a job.
You have an extra job like it's not like
you just let,
I can let my dog out in the yard.
Hey Buddy,
you gotta shit.
God open up the door.
He's gone.
Goes takes a shit there.
You got to take it down in an elevator
downstairs.
What if you're in a walk up,
right?
You're going to walk down seven flights
of stairs at two o'clock in the morning
because your dog has diarrhea.
Fuck is this.
This lady is walking down the street
with a God damn horse.
That is the one of the biggest dogs I've
ever seen.
What is that?
Mary lives in a 400 square foot,
two bed,
two bath.
My friend's daughter just moved to New
York City.
She got a job in New York City and she
moved to this place where she pays
$1,200 for a room that doesn't even have
a sink in Manhattan.
In Manhattan.
Yeah.
They have a community bathroom down the
hall.
She had us,
she,
she's a hot blade in her room and
there's no room for anything.
No refrigerator,
no,
none of that shit.
Oh,
it's a room.
No,
bought a room.
It's so little 1200 a bed.
There's a bed that sits there and then
there's like,
she has this little tiny area,
whereas a shelf and then she has a hot
plate that sits on the shelf.
That's it.
If you have clothes,
you got to stack them up in boxes on the
ground.
The best shitty in a World Bei Bei
$1,200 for a room.
If you're a kid,
like,
cause she's only 21.
Um,
think of your kid and you move to a New
York.
How much you make and what do you mean?
Are you even making 1200 bucks a month?
I mean,
you might make your probably clear 400
$500 a week before taxes,
right?
And then the taxes come.
You might be down to four,
right?
So you,
you,
what are you doing?
You're paying $1,200 and you make it 16.
You're,
you're living off of $400 a week to walk
around and take cabs and get food.
It's fine.
Fuck all.
That's literally why I moved to La.
When I started comedy,
I was going to go to New York and I
thought buddy was like,
you can be broken la and get away with
it.
Yes.
He's like,
you can't be broke in New York.
Yeah.
When I lived in New York,
I was doing road gigs and I couldn't
afford to live in Manhattan.
So I lived in new Rochelle.
I got a place in new Rochelle with a
little driveway.
I went to like,
I was a bottom half of a house and um,
look,
uh,
there's like a little driveway and
parked the car right in front of my
bedroom.
So if someone fucked with it,
I could hear it.
See it.
Yeah.
It was the only option that wasn't cheap
either.
But like living in the city was just
impossible.
It's like hundreds of dollars a month
just for a parking spot.
Ever afford that.
That's why I moved to La because I saw
some,
someone was telling me they were like,
you can get away with paying 400 a month
in La to have a room in a place with
roommates.
And I was like,
God is perfect.
Well I think comics are doing it right.
Like there's a lot of like Tony
Hinchcliffe when he lived out here,
when he first moved here,
he lived with like three other guys and
like they all split the rent.
Small one bedroom apartment or two
bedroom apartment.
You can get away with that and it's fun.
It's like it is fun.
You know.
It's not fun though.
The one guy who doesn't make it no shit.
He still calls you guys up to hey you
think are good to spoke Doritos Dave and
you're breaking up.
I got to go.
I'm on the hill on the hill.
Did you?
Yeah,
but that's always funny cause I was out
of the,
there's always one,
the guys that I moved out here or the
guy when I lived with,
when I moved out here,
they're all doing good stuff,
not comics,
but they're all doing this stuff,
which is wild.
This is good.
If they're not that they weren't common
better.
It was easier for me cause I didn't
want,
yeah.
I also think competition in those places
gets kind of thick.
You know it could,
it depends.
Some guy gets on some guy,
you know as you watch one dude get a lot
of like rise and then everyone else is
like,
why the fuck is he getting so much?
Right.
It becomes this,
you know I lived with,
I've only lived with,
the only comic I've ever lived with was
Dunkin.
That was the only for like six months.
Love Him.
Must,
it might not even been six months,
somewhere in the neighborhood of six
months.
I never lived with a comic.
I think you got booted out of his house
though.
He was living with a gal and then they
had a little gut of a struggle and you
called me up from a motel and I'm like,
come on,
live with me man.
Fuck it.
Come on dude.
Party this big old house living by
myself.
Like let's have some fun.
And he actually used my isolation tank
to get over his breakup.
Really?
Yeah.
He gotten their tank every day.
He would smoke weed and get in the tank
and think about life and just let it
size and wrote a journal and then left
it behind.
So I've read every page of it.
Call them up.
I was like,
dude,
what is all this gay shit?
What is this?
What do you got here?
First couple of pages.
I love angel.
I want,
yeah,
you,
yeah.
You don't mind if I put it online,
right page for page.
I don't know where that is.
It might have got lost in one of my
moves.
I might just turn up somewhere.
I was going to say you should do a time
release.
Like every day a new page gets released
online.
It wasn't really that bad.
It was just him,
you know,
like getting out of the tank and just
sweat sortings head out.
What's the first thing you think of when
you get out of the tank?
Oh,
it's very different every time.
I mean,
most of the time when I get an attack,
I'm just trying to chill out.
I've always had,
I always have so many plates spinning.
You know,
there's like so many different things.
I'm always thinking about like there's
podcasts.
Who's the future guests?
When am I doing stand up?
What,
what bit am I working on?
Right.
Let's go.
The UFC is coming up like,
Oh have I watched this guy fight before?
I got to make sure that I,
you know,
get my,
my,
my views in on different styles and
stuff and have my ideas about what I
think about these match ups.
And you don't sleep,
you don't sleep.
I sleep.
You're sleeping there?
No in the tank.
Oh No,
no.
I don't sleep in there.
Can people save saving the tech?
Uh,
yes.
You definitely can.
I would imagine that your own snores.
Doe would echo off the walls a little
bit and maybe that will wake you up,
but I'm sure I've passed out in there
before.
I'm sure I have many years that I've
been doing it.
I first got one 16 years ago.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
That's when I first got a tank.
I've got one in 2002 that's wild.
Yeah.
Do you do the cryo freeze too?
They do that too.
Yeah man.
I really prefer sauna.
It takes more time.
But,
uh,
I really like how Saunas make me feel.
But cryo gives you a for,
I shouldn't say I prefer it.
Here's the problem.
I have a sauna here,
so like I'm biased so I could just turn
it on and I'll do it way more often.
I have to drive to the cryo place.
Park my car.
That's a whole clothes off.
Climbing a cryo machine here.
No,
no,
no.
It's very complicated.
And you have to have a license and
you're carrying for nitrogen here.
Fuck Dude.
That's a cryo dude.
Jamie would like that.
You want to cry?
Oh Dude.
Hanging around.
I was thinking about that one girl that
died vegas cause she was doing it
without supervision.
We'll see.
How long was she in a four.
She did a different kind.
See there's two different kinds.
There's the kind that uses liquid
nitrogen and then you stand in this
liquid nitrogen and in that kind it's
only from the neck down.
So your head is not being frozen.
That's not as effective.
It's effective.
It definitely does something but it
doesn't do as much as the one where
you're standing at 250 degree below zero
air.
That's the one that I go to.
That's Cryo healthcare.
They're in La on La Cienega and then
there are about five miles away from
here in woodland hills.
So you just getting like a chamber?
Yes.
Under wearing gloves.
I got to where you were like crocs on
your feet,
something rubber on your feet,
like rubber clogs rather.
Um,
because you're,
you're going to wear socks,
socks go up to your ankles are up to
your calves rather like because your
skin can freeze.
Like you can get frostbite.
Like I know people that have been in
there too long and they've got a little
bit of burning sensation on their is too
long.
The most I've ever done is three minutes
and 40 seconds.
They don't let you do more than I think
a minute and a half on your first one.
They want want to make sure that you
don't freak out,
you know,
too sensitive and then you build your
way up to three minutes is the Max.
The only reason why I went further than
that because there was a guy worked
there and we were just trying to figure
out what you can take.
Yeah,
I was going to save you.
You did it because you want it to.
I wanted to see if I have court I could
take,
did you do it?
I've done twice.
I think vent,
two minutes Max.
This for me,
I felt like at full I felt like it.
Four minutes,
I would have had real problems.
I was like,
I was on the door of real problems at
three minutes and 40 seconds your brain
start.
Do you feel stuff?
We'd like,
does your head start getting fucked up?
It's hard to concentrate.
It's hard to stay cool like the whole,
the whole deal is just like,
stay chill,
cool.
Kill your you to keep it together.
You don't want to freak out.
But then my legs started involuntary
bucking.
They were doing this.
That's your body saying this.
This isn't,
we got to,
it was not.
It was like,
okay,
so my rational brain was still like 30%
operational.
Maybe at that point,
maybe 40% you're like,
you know,
thinking that you couldn't do math
problems,
you're not thinking clearly.
You could do math problems for the first
30 seconds and then you'd be like,
holy fuck,
holy fuck.
What if you just thought about one math
problem over and over in your brain and
circulated that shit until the end and
you'd be focused on it so hard then.
Then when you started to forget how to
do it,
then you know you're out and you can't
do it anymore.
Well one thing I do do is I do that Wim
Hof breathing method or I take these
gigantic breaths and then I let out 20%
and then I take another breath like as
deep as I can get my lines,
let out 20% and I concentrate on doing
that and time flies by.
That's what they do.
That's what those deep divers to write
those guys,
they go to those,
uh,
don't they do that?
Did they?
Cause they learn how to store breath.
I don't know what they do.
We were seeing those videos with those
guys.
They dive like,
you know,
and those dive tanks that they have set
up,
but the way they do it,
it looks like they in tons of breath,
they let a little bit,
they keep taking it in and sit there
like just storing it in there and you
know,
in the sax,
in their lungs.
I would think that that's not just
storing oxygen to that you'd be storing
carbon dioxide.
Right?
Cause you're not breathing out.
Yeah.
But they'd breathe out a little bit at a
time.
Hello,
fuck.
Do you convert oxygen to carbon dioxide?
I've always just,
just uh,
accepted that I never thought of about
the fact that air goes in.
Why isn't air going out without fuck is
happening and it's only going right
there.
Like how's it turned into carbon
dioxide?
A little dude.
It's just going in there and then it
comes,
right?
Like that's it.
I converted.
Yeah.
Right now that's ridiculous.
Mushy or conversion machine.
That's what we all are.
Big Conversion,
carbon dioxide conversion machines.
You learn that kind of stuff.
Like of,
of how quickly things happen when like,
like my college roommate had gout.
You know what I mean?
We're like blood turns around front jeff
at that.
That's crazy.
So like it's your,
it's like your fingers or your hand.
Anything we're blood has like a long
feet.
Yeah.
Fee.
It's usually legs and feet.
And I never understood until I looked it
up when he had it and I was like,
how do you get gout?
And everything online is like 50 plus is
at risk.
You know like high blood pressure.
Go to music.
It was 20 years old.
Jesus shouldn't had it.
You know they call it King's disease.
Yeah.
Cause they were fat and ate and drank
all day.
Just drink wine,
their feet,
you know,
fucking awesome.
That is.
Especially when everybody else is
starving.
If you'd be like,
please sir,
let me rest my swollen dead feed on your
head.
I've been watching biking's I get into
that show vikings.
I mean I've never seen him pretty God
damn good.
She's good.
I was super skeptical.
People telling me it was good.
I was like,
it's unregular TV.
How the fuck could it be?
And he was on,
it was on history channel.
Oh yeah.
Which is another one.
It's on history channel,
but it's a,
but it's a drama.
How the fuck it's based on historical
facts apparently.
Right.
Ragnar Ragnar Loft Brooke,
that's his name,
but it's fucking Badass show.
But one of the thing that's crazy about
the shows,
he really stopped thinking,
well this is really how it worked.
Like how king's treated regular people.
Totally.
They really got away with that and all
they were was just a regular guy.
I didn't have super powers.
No,
they didn't.
And everybody would just bow down to
him,
sire and they would kiss the rings and
they would just let them do whatever the
fuck they wanted.
It's so weird.
Fear of death,
dude.
It's crazy that even the army would
listen to this guy like that.
Anybody would let it and it catches guys
weird or that the army listened to one
dude.
Occasionally they will go fuck you,
and they'd killed the guy and then a new
guy would rise.
That's what we should be doing.
We should do all that shit.
Now,
today,
did you see the video of trump talking
about taxes?
Uh,
to what he said,
fuck,
I can check it out.
I'm going to charge you 25 be sent to
grow my instagram.
I sent it out yesterday.
Fucking amazing that that's the price.
There's two parts of me,
man.
There's one part of me that loves this.
Oh Dude,
I love it.
One part of me that's god Ha Craig
material.
There's so many fakes and phoneys and
ridiculous career politicians that have
to watch this guy.
Yeah.
Say,
listen motherfuckers,
you're going to pay 25% taxes and
everybody goes crazy.
Tears.
Yeah.
Cause like they can't believe he's
really saying it,
but it's the stuff that they would say
to if they didn't have any reservations.
Well it's maybe,
but I think a lot of those guys are just
like that.
Let's play it because it's hilarious.
I'm dropping
25% tax on gene Jana.
And I said to somebody that is really
the Messenger.
The Messenger is important.
I could have one man say we're going to
tax you 25% and I can say another.
Listen,
your mother fuckers,
man,
I'm telling you,
look
not in favor of the wall.
I'm pro immigration.
I'm not a favor of these ice busts and
all that jazz,
but shit like that one's me over.
I said,
well,
I just love the fact that the guy's the
fucking president.
And he said,
listen,
you motherfuckers,
you got to pay 25% taxes.
It says eight years before the campaign.
It doesn't say how many years.
Oh,
I love,
and I forgot.
Oh,
is it?
Is it 2011 it's old.
He looks the sense,
but what's,
you know what's so funny?
I was talking about on a stage,
it's still ridiculous.
I'm so tired of being yelled at by like
online about people hate him.
Like,
listen,
I'm not a huge fan of them either,
but so many people are like,
I hate him.
I hate him that now.
I kind of liked him.
Exactly like,
do you know how enough people say Shit?
They're like,
fuck you.
I'm so tired of you telling me your
opinion.
It's all the same to do.
Also what annoys me is when someone goes
fucking moron,
that's like,
that's it.
That's all.
That's what you did.
You,
you,
you put like,
that's not doing anything by going,
hey,
trump shuck my dick.
It's all right,
dude.
Well,
you got 'em.
Here's my take on that.
If it's that,
if it's fucking moron,
you're not even supposed to listen.
That's supposed to not even go in.
I know because there's not a,
this is not effective communication,
so if you engage that guy,
don't I just completely waste your time.
Even if you get upset at you completely
waste your time.
I wipe it away,
but I see it and I'm like,
oh,
come on.
This is the one that gets me as Nazi
fucking Nazi Nazi.
Oh yeah,
he's a Nazi and you're a Nazi fascist.
They throw these words around.
They really don't even know what the
fuck they're saying.
Like if you really think that everybody
looks likes trump is a Nazi,
you're missing.
That's insane.
You're missing a giant point.
You're,
you're fucking up everything.
You're ruining this conversation.
You're right about a lot of the shitty
does wrong here,
but as soon as you say he's a Nazi,
right,
and that there's Nazi,
everyone's a Nazi.
Well then when real Nazis come around,
you've get better.
Have a better name.
Yeah.
You can't with the court call Nazis,
you can't fucking take the word Nazi and
apply it to shit.
That's not Nazis.
That's dangerous.
Like that's a sale.
Like call someone a murderer.
Why'd you call him a murderer?
Because he yelled and insult at that
man,
okay,
that's not a murderer.
Right?
Like you can't do that same thing.
We call someone a Nazi.
That's not a nonsense.
He might be a moron.
He might be a fool.
He might be a into trump just because
he's a dumb guy and he likes the fact
there's a white guy in office.
But that doesn't mean he's a Nazi.
But it's also like the,
the biggest problem that I have is like
you're,
it's still illegal to be an asshole.
It's not illegal to be a dick.
Right.
If someone's,
if someone says something you don't
like,
right.
It's not against the law.
Right.
So like this idea of you tagging someone
like that,
the biggest criminal in the world
because they said something you don't
like.
It's crazy to me like,
well,
people are allowed to not fucking think
what you think is right.
Right Brian?
They're trying to redefine what's
acceptable by calling words violence.
Like they're calling saying hang speech.
Hate speech is real.
Right.
I don't know though.
See,
it's fun.
Little Fun.
It's real.
If you say something like,
fuck the Jews,
I hate all Jews.
Jews should die.
That's hate speech.
Okay.
It's to me it's this.
If you set,
if a guy said,
fuck the Jews,
I disagree with what he says.
Well you should say,
how do you fuck them?
Fuck them.
Genuine the front and about.
Fuck Dude,
go go around the world.
What he did kvetch after.
No,
but I think it's like Wah,
Wah,
but listen,
that person,
what hate speech to me is like a,
it's just a big,
huge term that can encompass so many
things.
I don't really know what it is,
right?
It does.
It incite violence.
The devices,
the Jews does that inside violence.
It shouldn't.
No,
that's just that.
If I said fuck your shirt,
it only inside the fund you to terrorist
shirt
close as soon as you,
the way you said shirt,
I was like,
yeah,
leading a shirt revolution you have
fuck,
shut your fucking shirt off too.
Fucking short broke.
Certainly Bro,
you surely way fuck the Jews works is if
someone also thinks fuck the Jews and
then you like find likeminded shitheads
but that's going to happen no matter
what.
But it's not going to have,
if you don't say it then.
So the idea is like,
can you suppress it?
Here's the problem with stopping hate
speech is like who's to decide because
they're pushing the boundary of what?
Hate speech so far.
Right?
Like if you call a trans woman,
a man that's hate speech like that,
there's,
it's kind what did,
that's just an accident.
Yeah,
it's still accidental hate speech.
Why?
That's crazy.
Because we live in a new world now.
See,
I can't accept that you don't go online
and now
if you do it out of malice,
like if you're,
if someone's like,
Hey,
I'm Margaret and a guy goes,
no,
I'm not going to call you that good
there I that then that's them being
proactively prejudice,
right?
Them being a dick,
they're being an asshole.
But some people are of the opinion that
this is all nonsense.
But if it's an,
I'm not taking,
taking their point.
But I do want to play devil's advocate
because I've had conversations with
people who are pretty intelligent people
than to say,
this is all nonsense.
And then this trans stuff,
and this is,
this is a trendy thing that people were
really getting into in summary Bore
really distorted.
Their perceptions of reality is really
distorted and they're being talked into
this because it's a thing that a lot of
people are doing it.
And so they're getting,
and um,
I hear that and I go,
wow,
I don't know if I believe that people
are willing to transition to another sex
because they're confused.
That's a big leap.
It's a giant ass leap.
But here's the other leap.
The leap is you telling someone whether
or not they feel a certain way.
And then the other leap,
here's the other leap.
What do you give a fuck if Bruce Jenner
wants to become Caitlyn Jenner,
I'll call our Kaitlin.
I don't care.
But if she thinks I'm gonna stop making
fun of her,
she's out of her fucking mind.
That's what it,
but that's what I mean.
So you should be allowed to just,
you should be allowed to mock at a
freedom that you would anyway.
Every six foot,
three person would size 14 high heels
gets mocked.
Just listen around clock because
anybody would get made fun of for any of
that in any other way.
Yes.
If you used to be a girl or you used to
be a dude,
and now you're a girl and someone's
gonna make fun of you,
and that's just the price you pay for
being a person.
But people make fun of everyone for
everything.
Everything.
You have red hair,
right?
Is My whole life,
your whole life.
But what?
I can't start a group against it being
like people trying enough of this
enough.
No,
just it is what it is.
Everyone has these flaws.
The kick of Ginger Ginger Day.
That wasn't cool.
No,
but no,
but you know what's so funny about that?
Those guys were so subversive.
What they're doing is showing how
quickly people jump onto things and go,
yeah,
fuck them.
Fuck them all.
So they're so smart.
I love that episode because it was like
that could be a real,
and that's how dumb people are.
People in the real world have told me,
I've been through it.
I wonder when we kick of Ginger Day is
they buy that's real to them.
But that's,
that's by the way I played,
uh,
I played golf with a buddy at the
country club that,
uh,
Caitlyn Jenner belongs to.
My first question does,
does she hit from the women's season,
the men's tees and the guy with me goes,
she hits from the women's taste.
I'm like,
Bull Shit.
See,
that's bullshit.
Is it bullshit?
Because you,
you,
you're a fucking Olympian.
You,
you were,
you still the difference between teasing
the men's tees?
I mean like distance 30,
40 yards.
Yeah.
Ah,
yeah.
That's like doing those pushups on your
knees.
Bullshit.
Yeah.
Good on your toes.
But,
but,
but wait a minute.
He used,
uh,
she was,
she had,
she has man structured muscle and then
go away.
That's all gone.
No Way.
Muscle.
There's no muscle while she's still
pretty fucking jam.
Not Really,
man.
I said no,
I'm going to be honest.
I don't think she works out at all.
And she's old already,
so it's not like your body has,
I still say you go back to her,
but she still has a Dick,
right?
Nope.
She had the operation.
Cut it off.
It's hot.
Is it gone now?
You're okay now you get women's tees
up.
Dick was there.
You gotta go.
You gotta go back to the black.
Yeah.
There's a lot of fence riders out there
in the Trans World.
Pick it.
You gotta pick dude,
you gotta come,
you gotta come or go.
That's another thing they're saying,
this is this,
I don't agree with this,
is they're saying that if you are a
person who is male and likes women,
if you are unwilling to date a trans
woman,
it's because you are a transphobic
bigot,
including if that Trans Woman's still
has a penis.
That is,
that's of no regard.
You know the funny thing of the,
of all this is I'm so happy to just be a
CIS gender men,
like a fucking,
I'm so happy to not have to worry about
it.
I don't have to worry about it.
No one's going to call me a bigot for
not liking a subset of a kind of a thing
that I like.
I just like a whoa.
I like women.
That's all I know.
I like,
that's it.
I'm fine.
They'll come around to you soon.
Take [inaudible].
They got Bruno Mars.
He didn't see it coming home on that was
said.
What did they say?
Appropriating black culture.
Cultural appropriation.
You see how many people came to his
rescue though?
A bunch of people were like,
that's bullshit.
He's a musician.
He,
what has he done that was he
appropriating black culture made zinging
awesome.
Made good music.
Yeah.
That's all he did that billionaire
songs,
a wonderful song and he made some
fucking great songs.
Artists.
It's bullshit to think people now can
stab at anything that you're like now
you're just trying to cause a stir.
They try it.
They take swings and sometimes don't
work.
Like remember when they were trying to
block bossy?
It's like fuck off.
Like okay,
just put it out.
Just want to put it out out there.
Trying to put it out and just giving it
a shot.
Yeah.
Bruno Mars,
they shut us down so fast and he didn't
say anything back.
Good for him.
That's my favorite shit.
It's kind of like,
you know how like Samsung and all these
other phone companies,
they make ads about iphones,
you know other,
all their ads are based on fuck I
iphones.
Apple never makes a response.
Of course.
That's the coolest movies to be like
whatever man.
Yeah,
that Samsung ad is stupid.
That's when they walk past.
The people waiting in line for an
office.
Had those.
Samsung always been like,
hey,
hey.
It's like the annoying little brother
and you're like,
oh dude,
get the fuck outta here.
We're just do your own thing.
They make the best second best phones,
set gear,
the second best phone in the world and
make the best second best facet.
You're number one at making the number
two phones sort of the Google phone is
probably better.
I think the Samsung probably sells.
What do you,
what about this ad as that was the Imac?
I'm a Mac.
I'm a PC.
Yeah,
those were so dumb.
But those are in the nineties man.
Yes,
those what I'm saying?
I'm saying currently they don't run any
ads like that guy from drag me to hell,
right?
No.
What was the movie?
He was Justin Long.
What was that movie he was in?
He was in a great fucking harm movie.
Like a real classic.
Can't be harmed movie Kevin Smith's one.
No,
no,
no.
He was in Tusk.
Right,
but that's not what I'm talking about.
There was one that he was in put up,
pull back it up with that.
Right though.
That is funny.
I forgot about those ads.
That's how long ago that way using
windows to write lately I use windows 10
it's fucking great.
There's nothing wrong with it.
Like windows 10 is in my opinion,
just as good narrowed.
Pretty boy.
Oh,
they're arguing with each other.
Mac versus pc.
Windows 10 is just as good as,
uh,
as Mac in terms of like,
it's a little different but it doesn't
crash.
I don't know.
I'm not having any problems with it.
It works great,
but I'm not even going to lie.
I'm not gonna be one these people,
you know,
like,
like james is a fucking tech genius.
He knows wizard.
Yeah,
he's a genius.
I when someone,
when someone says the accused of like,
why do you have a Mac?
And someone goes,
well judy,
it's great for the arts and it does this
and this.
I don't even lie.
I go,
dude,
I just pull up jeepers creepers in that.
But there was another one.
It was him that was a good one.
That was a good one.
Fuck you
guys.
The Guy who drove the old truck,
the mean deviled guy with the wings that
drove the old truck loved it.
It probably made 18 bucks.
It was probably,
she has 18 bucks.
The other movie through.
You're thinking of die hard,
but no,
no,
no.
He was in,
um,
see,
go to his,
uh,
you know that you don't have no,
it's good that he does.
The restaurant movie was pretty funny
too.
I am going to be,
he was definitely in a horror movie like
recently.
No,
no,
no.
Just go to the stop looking at images.
You're like a little kid,
but you're fucking instagram can't,
you can't look at like real words.
Where's the picture of the movie?
He was,
what is that right
there in there?
What's that?
Trump.
What does that say?
Track.
Confusing him with somebody else.
Yeah.
You gotta be,
there was like a some hell movie where
like,
he,
he had to go to hell.
She'll drag me to hell or something like
that.
I feel like drag me to hell is a,
uh,
a movie about a chick that was like
murder to came back to life.
Yeah.
That's a great,
that's the story.
That's a great story.
I think that's what it was.
I never saw it in that though.
He's the boyfriend.
He is.
He's in that one too.
When you're talking time.
Okay.
No,
no.
It was just a year ago.
Let me see what it looks like.
Okay.
That is it.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
I never saw that.
That's that is it.
It's um,
it was like,
uh,
which,
yup.
That's it.
Clay,
Clay Dalton.
There was another movie that sounded
like drag me to hell.
What does that,
is that guy shoving his fist in her
throat?
I was a good movie.
That was a good,
stupid movie that drag me to hell movie.
That is what the name of it was.
I was right.
But I was confused.
There's one with a woman,
like there's a woman on the cover.
It looks like she's like a silhouette
and she's screaming.
It's something about drag maybe dragged
you to hell.
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
Drag me to hell.
It's another one.
Same month.
Same movie.
It's a movie.
Yeah,
but that's not it.
You just named that you were like the
woman's screaming.
I did.
I did,
but that's not the,
that's not the same cover.
Perfect.
Easily issue houses in the back.
That's hard.
That's not it.
No.
There was another one.
I might,
I might have the name completely wrong
for the movie,
but it was about a woman.
See this is hard because I didn't
actually watch it,
but it was about a woman who got killed
and she came back and got the people got
her,
I don't know,
like high plains drifter.
You remember that?
Yeah.
Clint Eastwood.
Oh yes.
He was killed.
Yeah.
Came back to life and fucked everybody
up in the town.
Yeah.
That's good.
Western harm.
Western horror.
Right,
but a sneaky western harm movie.
Like you don't really exactly know
what's going on.
Where's,
there's not a western horror anymore.
Do they do shit like that was the last
western horror.
He said there was a western Ufo movie.
Cowboys and aliens.
Remember that?
Yeah,
but that's a piece of shit,
I guess.
You know what you could call now,
like you could do western,
like no country for old men.
Could be like a western.
That was a horror movie.
That guy was a monster.
Yeah.
I don't know.
A tour or if it's like more like a
terror.
Terror.
Yeah,
like a terror.
And that guy was a monster.
I mean,
might as well be fucking awesome.
How good is that fucking actor?
What does that gentleman's name with the
crazy hair?
Uh,
the mop on his head.
Come on.
What's wrong with me?
Sorry.
What movie?
No country for old men.
Uh,
Javier Bardem.
Yeah,
he's so good.
He's a beast.
Like you really believe that guy with
murder,
but you go,
well,
you know when you look in some actor's
eyes and you're like,
ah,
something real.
So inside of that he has that thing
where you're like,
oh fuck.
You know,
some actors just are like,
oh,
they're just playing a character.
Yeah.
When they don't have it,
it drives me nuts.
Now.
I know that guy looking at shit.
Look at us.
Look at his eyes.
Zoom in on his eyes.
Chan movie.
Is this from,
is that a new movie?
Loving Pablo?
I don't know.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
He looks exactly like him.
He did it again.
A bunch of weight for that.
He's always been kind of a thick dude
though.
But look at the picture of him above on
the blue shirt right above that and for
sure he's kind of a thick dude.
Nah,
not like Pablo.
Picture that public picture looks.
He's about 70 pounds.
Ever.
Look at that.
Look at a fucked up was psycho.
He was a good psycho.
That moves a fucked up movie cause it
just ends.
Yeah.
That's why the country for old men like
what?
Sometimes bad guys get away.
Fuck off.
Won't Coen brothers.
It was coen brothers,
wasn't it?
He was Frankenstein,
Frankenstein,
all the new monster movies.
He's got bleached blonde hair.
It's gay Frankenstein.
That's what happens.
The guy dies on the operating table
getting his cheeks done.
Gay freaking inside
was that.
He's taking it back to suck your deck.
Go to the picture above that cheese.
Get to to Dickson his neck.
A set of bolts,
the Tan suit above it right there at Tan
suit right there.
Yeah,
look at that.
God does the gay Frankenstein.
Yeah.
Is he a but it's selling you a house.
I'll kill you.
Always a bond villain.
That's right.
He was a bar.
That dead dude's a beast.
But the problem with a guy like that is
every movie that he does that's goofy,
takes away from degrading way you see
him.
If you see him in a movie like this,
right?
Like every movie,
no country for old men is so 100% legit.
That if he does a bond movie and he's in
some stupid karate scene where he's got
to like throw sidekicks,
the guy kicks him in the balls and he
bends over and the guy or caught
something,
it looks corniest shit it takes,
but there's like only so many actors
that got away like Daniel Day Lewis.
He's like the only dude that only did
shit he wanted to do.
Almost everybody else does things where
you're like,
why did you do that?
Right?
I mean they all like,
they all have to,
we'll nobody fucked it harder than
Dinero.
Dinero dude did some of the greatest
movies of all time and possibly the
worst movies in history.
It's done toilet water.
Just mostly toilet water ever since.
Did you see,
did,
did the output Chino paternal thing come
out yet?
When does that come up?
Have you seen that pregame?
Yes.
Dude,
look at the picture.
He looks identical.
I mean it's fucking creepy.
One next month,
next week show the Joe Paterno knew
those kids are getting molested.
Come on dude.
Of course.
He looking at,
he looks at it and looking identical and
everybody knew the guy was a pervert.
He was running a fucking children's
charity where he's taking care of kids.
I don't want to sound like one of those
guys,
but I don't give a shit.
I remember when he got caught,
when it,
when it came out,
I said to a bunch of people,
he's going to die soon.
Within like a month he'll die per sure.
And sure enough,
he died shortly thereafter.
This whole thing.
Yeah.
Cause I knew it was going to kill him.
Oh God.
That Sandusky thing.
So in this scene right here and the
trailer,
he's saying his wife is like,
his wife goes,
uh,
well,
you know,
he was,
he was with so and so.
Their kids' names and he goes,
he was with [inaudible] like his own
kids.
And then it hits him that he's like,
he was watching them.
So then it hits him like May,
Oh fuck he,
oh
jb.
Fuck my kids.
It's insane.
What the fuck man,
that wasn't that long ago.
No,
when was that?
That Sandusky arrest?
12,
2012.
So you should probably third 2013 easy
thing is they've already gotten rid of
all their sanctions and whatnot.
Penn state's already back all their
penalties and whatnot.
I'll tell you what the real quick money
baby will crazy thing is the original
investigator and to Sandusky turned up,
murdered his,
uh,
they found his laptop with a like a
destroyed hard drive.
And uh,
I think they never found his body.
I think he,
I think he fucking vanished.
Trial was in 2012.
2012.
Okay.
So that was a trial.
So he's arrested in 2011 find the guy
who was the original investigator who
turned out missing,
either turned up missing or murdered and
his laptop,
uh,
was found with a destroyed hard drive.
Like someone clearly got ahold of this
guy that he be fucking iced him because
he was going to destroy penn state.
I mean,
he was going to take down this tie
billion dollar industry.
What happened to your car?
Wow.
Um,
see what you get the story scroll,
make it larger there so I could read it
with my old eyes.
10 years ago,
prosecutor in Center County,
Pennsylvania took the day off work and
vanish.
Since then,
the case of rager car has been one of
the most intriguing and to,
I don't know if I'm saying his name,
write,
Kris Carr.
External.
Truecar,
truecar.
Nowhere is one of the most intriguing
talked about missing persons stories in
the country.
Investigators have taken dives to the
bottom of lakes,
dug up a grave,
chase more than 300 reported sightings
from Arizona to North Carolina,
drop flyers all over Slovenia.
Consulted a psychic,
interviewed a member of Hell's angels
and enlisted NASA technology,
but no one's been able to find the
veteran disk ditch district attorney who
was 59 when he disappeared.
He went missing that Friday morning,
April 15th,
2005 left behind a live in girlfriend,
beautiful and successful daughter and a
bank account that was supposed to fund a
fast approaching retirement.
Oh,
here's where the problem was.
He drove a red mini cooper.
Oh,
well that was fun.
Just make people kill himself.
As far as hard evidence goes,
it's a ball.
The police had the best lead they got
was a sighting of a woman who has not
been identified.
Bubba,
but let's listen.
Find out the,
the,
the conspiracy because the spirit was
that he was a part of the Sandusky
investigation.
Prevailing the serum.
This is the side d.
Did you Google send Dusky?
There it is.
Okay.
2011 when Penn state coordinator,
Jerry Sandusky,
got arrested in charge of sexually
abusing boys.
Where's vield that?
Dzhokhar who decided notch charged
Sandusky when his first victim came
forward in 1998 Dzhokhar cited a lack of
evidence.
The intrigue already simmering and
Dzhokhar's case exploded.
Sluice desperately trying to find a link
between the two cases,
but investigators said there's no
evidence that your car's appearance
disappearance had anything to do with
sending Dusky crimes.
Hmm.
That's not what I've read in another
story.
Cis Guy Saying,
I don't think it was a great stretch.
He was one of those guys have very
strong sense of justice and professional
discipline.
In light of what evolved and came to
beats closed,
I speak as a forensic pathologist who's
done some so many suicides over the
years and what can bring someone to that
point.
It's pure conjecture,
factual knowledge.
Hold on a second.
Go back up.
Still Stop scrolling.
It says,
the forensic pathologist said he
considered writing a book about your
car,
his ties to the Sandusky case and
whether or not it lead to suicide.
So he said it was not enough evidence
you'd have found him.
When people kill themselves,
they want to be found.
That's why they killed himself.
And sometimes most of the time,
sometimes they just go in the woods and
blow their brains out,
but in the fucking woods,
you know you don't,
he got rid of all that.
You know how many people disappear in
the woods every year?
Thousands and in North America,
but a guide this prominent in his,
like in his work and in his life that
has like that many,
he's got too many trails.
Do you know what I mean?
Mini Cooper,
that was isn't that fucking thing.
He's like,
I got a backpack and a bullet and I'm
just going to fucking high deep enough
to use all my water.
1600 people missing from our public
lands without a trigger.
A lot of those people are hiking and she
lesson on every year.
Okay,
I'm wrong.
It's like ever,
I've been reading people at Vegan
method.
It's about this,
that this happens a lot or was it,
but that one was saying 1600 people are
missing.
You know what I'm getting?
Here's where I'm getting my,
how many people killed themselves
outside?
Here's what I'm getting my information
from Bobcat goldthwait movie about big
foot.
I just realized where I'm getting my
numbers from because he has a movie
called Willow Creek and it's all about a
big foot size that people are creeped
out with a growing number of missing
persons international park.
Yeah,
but a lot of these people go fucking
hiking.
They don't go to kill themselves.
It's just people being foolish.
Well,
here's the thing,
man,
you don't have buddy of mine found a
skull when he was elk hunting humans,
Goldman skull while elk on how long has
that has to be dead for to be fucking
deteriorate like that.
She was mean.
It was deteriorated like at first of
all,
animals would get to it almost
immediately.
They smell it.
Birds come down.
They started taking it apart.
Coyotes find it.
Everything finds to be clean down to the
skull.
That's got to be quick.
Really?
Yeah,
you'd be,
you'd be surprised.
They'll clean you down to nothing in a
couple of days.
Holy Shit.
You'd be down to bones and day.
It's like that happens all,
it's if there's a population of animals
that are scavengers that are near your
body.
Dude,
a buddy of mine shot a deer.
Okay.
And um,
it wasn't the best shot in the world.
So he decided to let the deer bed down
to die.
Like sometimes you'll hit the deer like
in one long or something like that.
It wasn't the best shot and the deer bed
down and it was dark.
It was getting dark like he shot at last
light where you legally allowed shoot.
So they said we're going to come back in
the morning cause it's 30 degrees
outside.
The meat would be fine.
They go back in the morning,
there's nothing gone.
The coyotes ate everything except the
fucking head.
Like,
I mean everything.
Like he didn't get any of the rib meat.
All the organs were gone.
The legs were gone to down to the bone.
He said he'd never seen anything like
it.
300 pound mule deer.
It's a big animal gone.
He said he saw like six or seven coyotes
that day.
So he knew that coyotes were in the
area.
But you just take a chance.
He just like,
you could do one of two things.
Either bumped the animal,
which means you,
you go and it gets filled up with
adrenaline because it knows you're
coming close to it and then it runs and
then they can run for a mile before they
expire.
Or you just let it bed down there
peacefully.
It'll just lay down and die.
So that's what he chose.
His choice was just let it lay down and
die with the coyotes.
Got to it.
Fuck Dude.
300 pound animal to seven,
eight coyotes,
whatever it was that did it.
Maybe they called,
maybe other ones came from fucking half
a mile away.
I mean Yo,
this is deer.
Yo,
this guy left.
There's a fucking fresh,
it's Mike from the westwoods.
Yeah,
I think he was in an area with no
wolves,
so I think it was just all coyotes.
Coyotes.
The coyotes out here in la are so small.
They're like little tiny house dogs.
They're not like,
he had a little like bitch,
frail,
weird.
Like where I golf up in the mountain up
there.
We there all the time and they sit and
they wait for you to pass before they
can go across,
you know,
through the fairway and stuff,
but they're like little house dogs.
They're like 15 pound house dog.
We are lucky.
Those things are here.
This is the sort of the truth because
totally they weren't here.
They'd be rats everywhere.
Yeah,
they eat every throws.
Motherfuckers keep the rats in check to
keep the rabbits and check.
There's a system.
There's an ecological system and it
makes us uncomfortable because we don't
like to think about our own mortality
and something that wants to eat us,
but I like coyotes.
I like them.
I had a chance to kill a coyote.
They killed one of my chickens,
but I'm pretty sure that she had,
I'm pretty sure she had puppies or cubs,
I guess they would cubs.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure she had chicken.
Could have had it come into,
you know,
didn't could've run its mouth and
chicken has a comment.
How about that?
Jim is bound to go down and that
chicken,
you have a common,
my daughter went on rabbits and I'm
going to eat you.
My daughter's got rabbits.
Uh Oh.
We're going to take care of it.
You're not going to take care of it.
You're gonna play with those things
twice and then you're going to leave him
alone.
No,
no.
We're going to take care of it.
Of course they don't take care of it.
Yeah,
I'll give a fuck about those rabbits
because they have a dog,
right?
Dog and jostling.
Say you.
Oh,
he lies down.
They rub his belly,
cause kisses.
He runs around in circles.
You throw something,
he chases it.
It's way better.
Nothing grab it just sits there.
You go near it,
bite your finger.
Oh,
you can't throw that fucking thing.
But anyway,
the rabbit,
uh,
they live in the chicken coops,
big ass chicken coop and they follow the
chickens around.
And today one of the rabbits was trying
to eat the other chickens ass.
And so it's just falling around
literally with his little rabbit face
buried in this chicken's asshole.
And just in this chicken is trying to
get away.
But I kind of liken,
it was just bouncing around.
I mean knows to asshole all around the
entire chicky case for like five
minutes.
It was so rigid.
There's a sub category on porn hub for
that.
There's got to be chicken rabbit porn on
there.
Probably.
Yes.
Probably animate though.
Like enemies,
subcategories of porn.
Some of the anime shit that I stumbled
upon is so fucking like the technical
stuff is this stuff that freaks me out
the most.
It's weird.
People love people.
I don't know who likes watching a girl
get fucked by like 19 technicals,
like jamming her eyeballs or mouth and
her butthole and her and she had people
jerk off to that.
Started off with with Japanese.
For some reason somebody gave me an
explanation why Japanese dude like that.
Yeah.
I think the explanation is that Japanese
porn,
you're not allowed to show insertion
penetration.
Yeah,
it blurs.
You can't even show cartoon Dick's going
into Vaginas,
but you can show tentacles.
Ah,
Shit.
That makes sense.
So the fact that technicals look
remotely similar to Dick's,
they've decided to just go with
tentacles and your mouth and spit flying
out of your mouth and,
and they can't show jazz.
They can do,
but they can show technical juice.
You know what?
They can show where the ges is all
pixelated.
Like you can see the ges through a prism
dancing,
jazz pixelation.
You can't see the actual like hd four k
ages.
Nobody like that would be too much for
cages.
When I was a kid,
you couldn't have hard ons in porn
magazines.
They didn't have hard ons.
All the dudes had to have like limp
dicks.
What?
It was a law.
It was a federal law.
You better put that.
You better get that dead serious.
Like these guys had half hard Dick's.
They're always like half hard and it was
so confusing because you'd be a little
kid.
You Dick would be like a fucking total.
What's wrong with mine and you?
You'd be so horny.
And he'd be looking at this magazine
like this guy's right there and he's not
even horny.
He's right next to me.
He's like barely interested.
There was a lot they had to have good
limp dicks.
That's the trick.
Right?
See that's what's fun inside lived.
He couldn't have a mushroom Kaplan.
I'm a girl.
I'm a grower.
Not show her.
Yeah,
you'd have to have a real hog,
like a heavy one.
I'm nice when I'm thick,
but when I'm soft I can't be in the
magazine side a bit about it.
Before that the girl would be like her,
her mouth be open lipstick and her lips
purse and her tongue hanging out in the
dude would have his limp Dick rested on
her back like a drowning victim.
He pulled from a lake.
It's like what is this?
And then you just take the time to get a
hard on before we took these pictures,
man,
the fuck.
It's so weird that that's a law.
That's a fucking,
that's all crazy standards and
practices.
A certain companies are as like,
listen,
we'll let you show penises,
but they can't be filled with blood.
I don't believe it's standards and
practices.
I think it was a federal law,
but why would will be the difference of
showing pre vhs tapes.
Once vhs tapes came along,
then people got to watch actual hard
porno and there was like a loophole.
There was a loophole that existed
because the pornographic magazines,
they weren't allowed to show insertion
and they weren't allowed to show
erections.
So there was this,
it was as weird and it wasn't that they
couldn't show the lips of the vagina.
They had to be covered up by like hair.
Right.
It was something like that.
Like they couldn't show hustler always
did though.
I think,
well,
they were the first one to do it.
Playboy never did.
I know I always had bush.
Playboy would have like bear,
you'd barely see Bush,
you know,
you'd see like a shadow of a Bush,
like girls looking pretty.
Right.
Whereas hostler was like,
let me watch you piss shit on his guy's
chest.
Page one Pfister asshole.
Come on with.
It was a different thing,
you know?
But when,
when we would find these magazines like,
oh,
he's in the woods.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I have a whole bit that's based on a
true story about fun and that what Larry
Flint's like trials are kind of about.
I think so.
I think some of them were about that.
Yeah.
But see,
obscenity is one of those weird things.
And I know we attributed to,
uh,
Vincent Scalia,
but people corrected me.
Judge Scalia is that his name?
But it's not him that says Scalia,
that guy,
it's not him that said this.
It's another guy who said this.
I don't know what pornography is,
but I know when I see it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Well there's another version of that too
that's like,
I don't know what blank is,
but I know it when I see it.
Right,
right.
There's a few,
probably the,
probably a few of those that erroneously
attributed to people,
but,
um,
there's a guy named Max hardcore.
Do you remember that guy was a porn
actor?
Yeah.
That guy went to jail for obscenity and
he did hard time and he had some hard to
watch stuff.
Like he had stumped some stuff.
You're like,
wait a minute,
what?
Like I found out about it because people
weren't like,
hey man,
this is the great stuff to jerk off to.
Right.
They were like,
why you got wash this?
What in the fuck is this?
This guy used a speculum to open this
girl's asshole.
He pissed in her asshole and then he put
a straw and made her drink his piss out
of her own asshole.
I gotta get Outta here for a second.
I got to go finish up.
But it was like there was a lot of like
really,
really fucked up stuff website that
basis.
Do you know he fucked?
Do you ever heard of that?
That's all they do is fucked up crazy.
Like there's nothing sexual about it.
It's just,
it's just like defacing some buses
fucked.
But the point is that this guy went to
jail for that.
Like nobody else almost did prime to
battle obscenity charges in Connecticut
and Cincinnati Rather.
Um,
that's in 1,998 though.
25 years in prison.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Porn magnate and Haas or publisher,
they're like,
wow,
that's crazy.
Oh wait a minute.
Chart the same low cow where a judge and
jury sentenced him to 25 years in prison
more than 20 years ago that he did.
So he did he actually go to jail time?
He served time,
but yeah.
Wow.
He was living in Columbus where I'm from
and he set up his big house,
which he,
from what I heard,
he had played on making it like a
playboy mansion type place and it was
right next door to the Columbus School
for girls and I think that causes some
of the first problems for him.
Well,
it was just prospect.
That's just smart.
That's a smart real estate.
Yeah.
It's a good place to,
if you're going to be decent and shot a
house near Lake.
Yeah,
man.
That just setting up shop,
just learning the territory,
location,
location.
If you're a coyote,
you know where the cats live.
Well that's like guy like perverts.
I got into selling ice cream to kids.
It was was like you can't play them.
That's very intuitive.
It's like people think of that and to
dismiss that,
that's not a big deal.
Like the Larry Hall that Larry Flynt
Hustler think that's a very big deal.
It's a very big deal.
They were trying to push this guy in
jail for something that people enjoy
buying.
Yep.
Cause I bought it.
Yeah,
they liked it.
That went for you got a hustler.
Yeah.
Awesome.
What do you guys get his hand
in his pants got hustler play in pocket
pool.
Hot Tub.
Like they like it.
They want to buy his product and you're
like,
no,
you can't like it.
What the fuck?
It's my favorite thing in the world.
You can't tell me what I like.
Yeah.
I mean there was,
this wasn't that long ago,
man.
Think about that 98 that's a 20th
season.
That's crazy.
20 years ago I almost went to jail.
I remember going with my dad to the
movie rental place by his house and had
one of like those back rooms.
No.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Saloon doors to come in and as like a
kid,
my dad would be like,
where are you going?
It was like,
oh look at a section over here.
And then he'd be on the other side and
he tried to like sneak in to take like a
peep.
But even like the boxes and then they
got smart too.
They put covers over the boxes.
So you get to like move a thing back to
see what the box was.
Well the thing that weird feeling was
when you would go through those beads
and you would be in that room with those
other perverts or just like super
uncomfortable to be near each other.
We're all going to be doing the same
thing in 20 minutes.
One time I went to an actual porn store.
What is it?
What do you mean?
Like a hardcore store.
I was like x,
x,
x videos like a shop and shit.
Like they sold dildos and videos.
Right.
And that's all they sold.
That was their big like let's stop
pretending it's got the shit,
cut it out.
I'm going to go to the back room of a
mom and pop store,
which says adults only.
No,
no,
this is like the whole store.
And you just felt so weird and the guy
behind the counter is talking to me
like,
hey man,
what's up?
I'm like,
hi,
you fucking talk to me.
I'm uncomfortable that you guys have
sexual urges.
You guys are out creeps,
not me.
I'm different.
That's why I have to every guy in there
get out of,
I like these guys fucking the other guys
in there,
but that's so annoying.
When they tried to talk to,
I went to there.
There's one here,
there's one in west Hollywood that's
like a sex store and the guy was like
being really friendly and he's like,
Hey,
what's up?
What's going on?
It's like,
you know what's going on dude?
It's,
this isn't target.
I'm not maybe here for a vacuum or
greeting cards.
Yeah,
we're not a fly tying.
Oh Shit.
I'm here for Weird Porno Shit.
Just let me get the thing and stop
making me feel weird and tackle.
You're going to tell me about the best
spots right now.
These barbers are pretty good man,
but those dildos will do the trick and
tell you what,
if you're just willing to take the
drive,
Sacramento La fucking salmon fishing is
off the chain anyway.
Amount 42 bucks for this angel bead.
Here you go do to date and tackle and
anal beads that
tackle and they end up fishing and
fucking fish place.
It'd be called like a fish.
You're like the fuck to I opened up this
shop,
dude,
it's called fishing and fucking Ooh,
tell he almost totally,
totally work.
But the problem is nobody buys things
from a store anymore.
You can just go order a Amazon fucking
Dildo online.
You get it shipped to your house and one
day Amazon prime prime.
Same Day.
If you get an early enough,
this is a real legitimate question.
I'm not playing stupid.
Does Amazon sell masturbating and tackle
our competition?
These guys just beat around the bush.
We're fishing and fishing and fucking,
they masturbate all you want.
I brought a fuck rather fuck.
You don't know what the fuck you're
talking about
over here.
You're gonna fuck your own hand.
I'm going to have somebody else.
Fuck it.
Does Amazon Sell Rubber Dicks?
Ghada Ghada Jamie,
how many of you ordered from them?
Don't lie.
And he's like,
yes,
of course.
Worked for a company that did that,
so I'm sure they'd sell them on Amazon.
That's sold rubber dicks.
Yeah.
You know who sometimes sends me Rubber
Dick's for and I asked a fleshlight
those people at flashlight and in Austin
when I was doing moontower years ago,
I'd be friended a few of the people
there and they were like,
we'll send you some stuff.
So they sent me like a few of the
flashlights,
but they also sent me bags at Dick's
bags.
A Dick's rubber ducks on them.
You Go,
you could buy a bunch of rubber Dick's,
you can get off.
Did they have rubber vaginas or are they
discriminatory and anti male in their
practices?
Come on,
you fucks.
I don't see a single rubber vagina
sexist bullshit course because that
would be objectifying spank.
Spank Bank.
What does that,
it's just an actual bank.
Just poorly named frank fleshlight
daylight parody.
Oh,
it's a show.
It's a,
it's like a book.
It looks like a book.
What did you type in,
Jamie?
It's Al.
It's a song and type in men sex toy.
Do men sex toy.
See if that does it.
Fleshlight was our original sponsor,
the first sponsor of this podcast with a
flashlight.
Just pills,
nothing.
Jen,
Samer,
Dick's all day long.
It's a rubber Dick.
Is that a rubber Dick to put your Dick
Inside?
That's the extender.
You put your tickets out of another
dick.
Penis extender.
It says delay,
ejaculate.
Wait,
there you go.
We'll simulator the aircraft cup,
but look how they say it.
Male simulate young girls,
nails,
toys,
adult products.
They got every tag.
Scroll back up to that Dick one.
Look at this.
Look what it says.
It says delay.
Ejaculations.
Yeah,
like forever.
Like you'll never come.
You're not having sex.
Do you want to stop coming?
Like put this on.
It's a big clear fake Dick that goes
over your Dick had this guy,
Steve,
come kick you in the cock.
You won't come for hours.
That's up fucking rough road for a dude
to the tiny deck.
If you have a micro Dick,
there is not a god damn the micro penis
saying there's nothing they can do.
How real is that though?
It's real.
Is it real?
Hundred percent you're so funny.
How real is that?
Well,
how many people have micro penises for
real?
It's a real issue.
Guys have like one inch dicks.
I think it's a real issue.
An inch when it's filled with blood rock
hard,
that's an inch rock hard.
You got this.
That's their penis.
The whole Dick.
Not even my full failure throw thinkers
because it's too big because a lot of
guys are seeing this right now and going
like duke is that big said girls don't
care about so it was bro.
It's not.
That's not,
that's not what matters.
That's what they say to guys with little
ducks.
They go,
it's fine.
I love it.
I like it.
I don't care.
Really.
So you're saying this is a man that half
of that,
that's a man's penis.
Girls have no problem mocking it.
They would just mock it.
The market in front of her friends in
front of you,
like guys,
a little dicks.
It says high.
It was all I all,
I couldn't fucking debt.
I scan because you can't retire.
You can't be like can you push these
big?
But if a guy did talk like that,
he would be a monster.
Like a guy was talking about a giant
poster.
Yo Dude,
I had a breakup with her.
My balls would fall in.
I'd be fucking,
I'd be strapping a two by four to my
ass.
No.
See I was lacking from getting sucked
into the boy.
Four questions about the life of the
micro penis reveals about the folding
0.6% of the population to see.
It's enough.
That's enough.
That's dude.
That's if you have a hundred people that
means what?
How many people is that less than one?
Not even one.
No wait 6.6 so 200 people.
You have one two to 1.2 yeah.
Right.
That's a lot.
200 people.
So if you at the comedy store six out of
a thousand that's right.
If you're the comedy store,
just two people in the room on a full
house on Saturday night that I have,
my one guy has a micro tech,
well you gotta think it's 50 50 men
women.
So one guy in that room was a micro
Dick.
So if you make a joke about a micro
Dick,
one guy's like,
okay,
no,
the joke before,
he loves so much,
he's still laughing,
but in his head he's like,
no,
don't you agree when you're shitting on
giant pussies,
this guy's the best.
I love the major pussy joke.
They're too big because these are just
too big and they are too big.
It doesn't get in the way.
Perfect.
If want to have to urinate,
it's there from me.
But that's crazy to think if a girl
dates a guy with a micro penis and she
just sticks around because she was like,
well,
he's a good dude.
Well,
um,
I know a lady who had a few children,
she had three children with a
microphone,
decided no with a regular peanuts guy.
He's a handsome fellow.
I'm sure it was quite a sturdy cock.
Paul,
like an ax handle hefty.
He looks like he's of Viking.
Um,
but anyway,
uh,
those kids had a blown a hole through
the old car port and so she decided to
get everything all stitched up.
She said it was the most painful thing
that she'd ever done.
Totally more painful than childbirth
because they go in there and cut.
I'll say that again.
They cut and then they stitch that bitch
up to like a finger gets broken when you
put it in there.
It's like tighter than anal and I'm
unbelievably painful and I can't even
strap yourself in.
Num Num num goes numb because like you
ever have surgery when they cut all
those nerves,
a lot of times that nerve damage.
Yeah.
Like my knee,
I had a acl reconstruction on one of my
knees with what's called a Patella
tendon graft.
They open you up,
they'd take a big,
like foreign slice.
They open you up and they take a piece
of your patella tendon,
screw all these things and stitch it
back up.
That whole area.
I had that thing done in like,
fuck 1994 it's still numb.
Like my knees numb.
None of the nerves have repaired.
No,
not over where the,
uh,
the incision is.
It's taught like I'm touching it right
now.
I literally,
it feels like someone stuck novacane in
it.
I can touch to the left.
I feel it.
I touch to the right.
I touched right with that.
Scar tissue is,
it's numb.
Nothing.
Your pussy can go numb too,
bro.
My Pussy will never go numb,
You pussy can go numb bro.
Fishing and fuck and you pussy Mako
numb.
Yeah.
Well fishing and fuck.
And you just got to have a beer can
sized hog to fill that gap or you got a
gapper a tall boy.
I can't imagine the pain of that shit.
The only thing that I,
that I know the most painful thing I
ever had was when they stick a fucking a
tube in,
in your,
in your Dick Hole,
when they're fucking testing you for
shit and they fucking shove up to the,
Oh my God dude,
that's a pain that I never want to feel
over again.
Well,
I just would assume that they would have
figured out a way to fix dicks.
I think they think that's funny.
I think they're just like,
fuck them.
I don't think there's anything they can
do.
Does it all the way around.
Crispr crispr is going to come around
and that's going to fucking,
you know what crispr is as Jeanette,
this is new tool that they have to a
altered genes and altered dna where you
can like pick baby shit.
You gonna be able to pick baby shift for
sure.
That's wild.
That's 100% they're probably already
doing it in China.
Sort of six to 18 years from now,
the Olympic Games,
we're going to see some just genetic
freaks from going to be amazing.
I can't wait.
We're going to be like,
wait,
what the fuck is that person?
14 year olds for the air breaking
records.
Fucking quadruple somil over people or
they're playing basketball,
Adh,
vertical leaps and shit.
They're gonna like jump from the free
throw line and the other side of the
court and do flip through the air and
slam dunk and everyone's going to go,
wait,
what?
No,
everyone's going to go off ma.
Yeah,
seen it.
At that point we'll be just a normal
fucking thing.
Did you see that video that I sent it to
you Jamie?
That dog that jumps through the air and
you can't,
you literally can't believe how high the
dog jumps.
Did I say I'm going to send it,
I'll send it to you right now,
but is this I sent it to,
I know I sent it to Cowen cause he's a
sharp are both dog freaks but it doesn't
even make any sense.
Like you,
you look at the video and you go like,
what the fuck this one?
Nope.
That's not it.
But let me see this dog.
Let me see that one.
We are the body on the other thing.
Little Stud jacked here.
He goes,
boy.
Oh,
he's running up the wall and I've seen
this crazy.
This stuff is insane.
It's crazy.
That dog just jumped.
It looks like he jumped 18 feet in the
air.
He did it least right?
Yeah.
That looks like 18 feet and he bites the
rope and so that it pulls them down
slowly so he doesn't get hurt.
That's amazing.
The guy helps it.
Guy Catches him to do.
That's a fucking crazy dog.
Pit Bull can leap four meter walls.
What?
Four meters?
They're not regular dogs,
man.
Look at us.
See Fecha Veggie at Holy Shit.
That is incredible.
Find this fucking dog.
Oh,
also I wanted to ask you about this.
Have you seen mass wrestling?
Do you know what that is?
Mass wrestling.
Do you know what it is that type that
in?
This is nuts.
Mass wrestling.
Before I forget it,
I wanted to tell you about it.
People like there's like a,
there's like a bar.
Look at this.
What are they doing?
They,
there's like a bar.
Do they both have to grip onto and
they're pulling it or the coaching you
get legs.
How many people die doing this?
Ah,
isn't this fucking insane?
Do a lot of weight.
Ton.
I mean,
Dude,
look at these two dudes.
It's all that's all grip and leg
strength and shit.
Yeah,
it's wild as shit.
I got watched like 50 videos of it.
I got so soaked into it.
I was like,
how?
Why?
Why are people doing this?
It's like tug of war with like a
statement with something stable.
You know,
I'm sending it to you right now,
Jamie.
You got to see this.
Uh,
it looks like we'll do these guys.
Are they blurring out that guy's hog?
I would like that it was a hog butt ass
naked.
I mean,
I originally got in the right light.
There's a little pixelation.
I originally got into this because I was
jerking off to it.
That's why I wanted to see this stick.
I thought they had their hand.
So they're holding on holding on this
like this.
This,
yeah,
like the guy on the left is winning,
but he's all arms.
Look at his little bitch ass legs.
I got my money on the guy on the right.
I don't like the way the guy on the
right or the left rather has
overdeveloped his arms and
underdeveloped his legs.
That guy's going to quit.
They got in the left.
Yeah,
he's got no legs down.
That's going to give out.
The guy on the right is Russian.
It looks like he's from a hut in the
middle of Siberia.
He,
his whole family lives in a yurt.
You have to kill him.
The left did not run.
Look at his legs like he'll get his
calves.
That guy's not,
he's not fit.
See,
told you.
That's why I'm a good mma commentator
called it.
I know when I see it,
dude,
it's just like he's jacked.
You look at his upper body and his
forearms and shit and his biceps and his
shoulders.
I'm like,
the guys jacked.
There's no leg strength there,
but he's got zero in his legs,
which means his mind is weak.
That's what it means.
His mind his week.
He wants everybody to think he's strong,
but he's not doing the real hard work.
Nobody gives a fuck.
If you're doing squats,
you don't,
nobody notices.
Okay.
If you do push ups and you do bench
press and you're fucking tits pop out,
everybody sees it,
watch this dog.
You ain't gonna Shit.
You ain't even going to believe this.
This doesn't even seem real.
Look at this dog flies.
I think that's a Belgian malinois flies
whole just flies.
And then they have them land on a
cushion,
which is pretty sweet.
Look when he jumps off that guy's
shoulder,
the guy shoulders.
But that's gotta be 23 lead jumps.
I mean it's at least 15.
He's at least 15 feet in the air.
What's even cooler is a dog that he's
flying.
Um,
the,
uh,
it's send it official on instagram one
all one word,
send it official.
That's a one of them instagram page that
has a bunch of crazy shit on it.
It's always,
there's a lot of those that are pretty
good.
I follow.
A lot of them will do the original,
like the send it quote,
you know,
that's from,
you've seen those guys that,
have you seen those guys?
He's like,
come on Marty.
Stand at and he just like jumped shocks
and fucking just do that makes me laugh
so hard.
Every time he's like,
what'd you go do?
He's like,
I'm a fucking sand it truck.
It just shoots it off a shitty fucking
ramp.
Hold my beer while I send the fucking
sand it.
Have you seen hold this beer on twitter?
If you ever seen that?
I call my beer.
Yeah.
I think it's hold this hold.
This is the actual twitter account,
but it says hold my beer is the name of
it.
Oh right,
right,
right.
That one is,
that's an hold.
My beer can't go wrong with that one.
No,
that stuff's hilarious.
If you can deal with it,
if you can deal with it,
cause sometimes you're going to watch
people that are to get absolute brain
damage,
but I love it whenever it's not me.
There's one where a dude is standing on
a hill and a bale of hay is coming
towards him and his bail hay.
It looks like it might waste six 700
pounds.
Right.
And it's huge.
He's taken,
jumps up into the
air like he's trying to get over it and
he does it make it and he goes fucking
flying and he got hit by a bus.
I love that shit.
I mean the dude goes,
if you ever seen a bay,
one of those big ass.
Yeah,
circle.
Bill's a hail it bigger than this table.
Huge.
Those are so fucking bigger than a truck
tire.
They're so heavy and this dumb fuck
thought he was going to jump over it.
My favorite is grossly overestimate how
well there it is.
Come on dude.
My sister again,
I mean the fact that he's alive,
fucked up.
He is lucky he's not paralyzed.
Look at this.
Boom.
I mean he did a full flip through the
air.
That fucking thing is so heavy.
You just no way you would pick that up.
You know my favorite is the medicine
balls.
When people bump the,
you know,
and they would be able to do medicine
ball challenge where they run at each
other.
If you ever seen that,
they'll tow both grab a medicine ball,
run shot at full speed and jumping and
whoever gets hit the furthest,
but sometimes people do with their kids.
Oh Chin.
Like a Dan will be just fucking around.
You see a kid go flying 30 feet in the
room.
Jesus Christ.
Oh that's my favorite shit.
I love there's a,
there was one on there that's like fail
army or fail blog or something and they
showed the same kind of fucking stuff
where people would just have this crazy
idea of what they would do to get away
from things that other people aren't
doing.
It totally charged fucking sidestep.
I'd decide stuff.
Um,
that was,
that's always jump over it.
That's always been an inside joke in a
mma forums about sidestepping that uh,
if someone who's coming after me,
I just fucking side sides,
I'll admit,
I just sidestep.
Most people just don't know what to do.
They stand there and freeze.
I just charged up get all the way,
like I got it planned out.
People are going to swarm you,
swarm you like a Zombie bite your face.
Like wait,
which side?
Snapping them.
Dude.
Sidestep.
Sidestep a mall.
But people think they could do or if
they're forking bowl was coming after me
or just step aside matadors or faggots
with total fucking punch.
I'll use your,
uh,
we'll use your fake martial arts videos.
Those guys.
Those are my fucking dude.
Those are my favorite.
I resist putting those videos up cause
there's so many of them get sent to me.
It,
I can't keep putting him up.
The guy that like a wind technique like
with his breath is because the other
guy,
great page on instagram.
Make Dojo.
Is it Mick Dojo or mcdo Joe Life.
I forget which one it is.
We told you a life.
We mic Dojo.
Mic Dojo.
They call them macdill like a Dojo is a
martial arts school.
Nick Doe Joe's like a mall martial arts
school.
That's what we would call like cheesy,
shitty martial arts schools.
Mick Dojo,
watch this guy.
Watch this guy go go full screen on this
one.
And he just wants to fucking
preposterous.
The guy comes out and with a sword and
he uses his power and the guy goes
flying.
I buy,
I buy every second of it.
Old Japanese guy.
I buy this goofy white guys who would
have been the guys in boyle heights.
They were saying,
we're here for your community.
We love
that.
They would be the same guy.
He's old,
Dorky liberal guys who probably call
themselves feminists and they just
flying through the air with her.
Kido suits aren't,
he is fucking this guy up.
He's fit fucking this dude.
He leads him around and then sit down to
the ground.
Well,
you know as a feminism,
more likely to get tossed around.
It's almost looks like a coordinated
dance.
It's so silly.
They're also silly.
What does that one next to it?
The guy with the karate outfit.
What is he going to do?
Is that a girl or guy to guy?
Oh,
oh my God.
He's doing flips on his head,
breaking the boards and then flipping
onto his feet.
So he's crushing or the blocks of stone
with his head.
Yup.
What does it sound like?
Oh
my God,
he's doing it like,
like flipping
one more.
Yea He did it.
If that ever comes up,
do you need to flip and land on
someone's Dick that guys at taekwondo
outfit on?
That doesn't make any sense to me.
That's so weird.
What could those be made out of the
shittiest rock known demand?
Like if you pissed on it,
we'll probably break.
It can't be rock.
Yeah,
it's,
it's some sort of shitty ass bitch ass
concrete pit yet.
Did you get that bag of bitch ass
concrete?
We ordered.
Yeah man you got some bitch ass.
Fuck people up breaking shit with my
head.
But there's a lot of people out there
that buy into that stupid stuff man.
But my point about it is like there's a
lot of people that buy in anything.
That's why people join cults.
That was why people,
they fall into these ideas and they
believe him wholeheartedly and then you
know are new religious like the all the
new cool religions where like the dude's
are like,
remember,
I think I talked to you about it where
like there's these new motivational
speak speak churches where it's like
that's all it is.
Yeah.
I read about one recently that uses a
friend of mine synagogue from where a
friend of mine goes for his service.
He's Jewish where he,
him and his family go.
These people rent it out like on some
days and they'd come down,
they have this rock and roll sort of
rock and roll church,
but the guys like this charismatic Sorta
Halfass Waco Dude and they're all good
looking like Koresh type shit.
It's like five or six of these guys with
varying degrees of bullshit a tube and
they're all,
they're all rich.
They're all tall,
super,
super rich.
Tons of money,
man.
Well,
especially if they can get like young,
really wealthy people who are not long
good looking kids.
My friend went to one,
he was saying,
he was like,
dude,
you have to see that.
He's like,
the women that were there were,
every one of them was gorgeous.
Yeah.
My buddy had a personal assistant,
he was a producer of a TV show and he
had a personal assistant and his
personal assistant was,
she was nice,
but she was off like she was just,
it was,
there was some wires,
it would just,
you know,
[inaudible] they just weren't
connecting.
Right.
And she started going to this church.
He's like,
you would love it because it's not like
a regular church.
Like we just sang the whole things.
We talk about thing.
They give us a haircut.
Your life like,
okay,
do you have to give him money?
Like how's that work?
Tons of money.
Let's talk.
And then you give me money.
I don't have any services.
I give,
I'm not really big on services.
The law get together and talk and then I
get paid.
And then how like mansions,
I like to live in a magic.
So we'll we're gonna do is I'm going to
regurgitate some anthony robins quotes
and I'm going to tell you about life it
and then a little bit of Jesus.
I'm gonna throw some Jesus in there to
seem legit little sprinkle of Jesus.
We love Jesus.
We're not heavy.
Jesus.
You know,
we're,
we're like Paleo.
Ask
Paleo Church,
Paleo.
But we also like spaghetti.
It's like,
it's okay,
I'll snack on it.
Snuck on Spaghetti.
Jesus teens.
I'm going to,
I'm not gonna lie,
I'm not going to,
I can't say no.
I'm not willing to give up my salting.
Nope.
You know,
I would go paleo if it wasn't for
crackers.
I like Ritz.
I like to put on the bits every now and
then I want to put on the wrist.
This is what I like putting on the Ritz.
Give me money.
Yeah,
man,
there's a lot of loss people out there.
Uh,
and then there's people that come along
and then the capitalize on it,
on those lost people and then they
figure out like,
oh,
there's a market and capitalizing on
loss people and they ramp that shit up.
Total hopper.
You know who I find is the big who like
makes now that now that like,
because I'm like buying all sorts of
stuff for this puppy.
The Co,
the stuff I should have gotten into was
like tricking people into needing pet
stuff.
Like if I got to vent a pet thing,
like what thing would you invent?
Invent one right now we can just see no
started out in the front of fucking it.
Just put it out.
You've got your and your dog toys right?
When you get to that register,
I'll tell you what,
that's when you're most susceptible to
impulse buy.
That's where we put dollars jet blue.
So puppy toy or some shit.
Puppy Dildo.
Be Great.
If the store was empty and all you had
was stuck by the register cause you're
like they don't buy out there man.
They buy right here.
That's all we did.
And fucking fishing.
Ride the register.
It's a robot fuck doll for your dog.
I thought about it.
I been thinking about this for 25 years.
It's a robot phone that I've got these
Japanese scientists involved and we
figured out the perfect height.
You don't really need all can fuck it.
Don't snip your dog man.
Don't,
don't fucking don't neutered or spayed
or nothing.
Just tell you what your robot photo
misconception is that a big dog can't
fuck a little robot dog.
Cause again,
watch,
he'll get low.
So this is like,
you don't really need the one that you
can't sell after your dog dies.
And then I came in,
you got a dog dude.
You know,
ever since Ross,
he died,
his robot fuck dogs just been sitting in
the garage had been hoping it's,
it's sad.
Someone could come on and come in it,
it'd be bop one more humans and just to,
just for their youth.
That is an issue when your dog tries to
Hump your kids like
problem.
Yeah.
My uh,
my massive has a,
has humped people before you got to let
one kid go,
you gotta go.
Yeah.
You've got to sacrifice the one you
liked the least.
You know what I mean?
Anything disturbing about 140 pound dog
named Johnny Cash and wants a hump your
leg,
you know,
he's a sweet dog.
But if he wasn't,
if you wasn't to be a real issue
problem,
your real problem.
Yeah.
What do you say?
Hey,
hey,
cut the shit and they look at you and go
[inaudible] hold in front of you do it
all the time.
This is what feels good to me.
It feels good to me and I'm doing it.
Did you ever have moments where you were
when your dogs have ever seen you like
jerking off or having sex or anything
like that?
No.
Jury got in front of my dogs.
Never.
Or have sex in front of him.
No,
I did.
I do it first day just to let them know.
I've heard about people that are having,
I'm going to do it all comes in and
starts licking their feet.
I've heard that kind of shit.
Yeah.
Heard that shit and then they come
harder
and the girl was like,
why don't you come so quick?
I was look at my feet.
What?
They'll probably bomber out.
We're trying to uplift my balls and I
came like a wildcat.
Wow.
Heads.
They just get a bunch of dogs around and
lick your feet.
Sure.
People are doing that.
I mean that has been always been the old
thing about peanut butter,
peanut butter,
peanut peanut butter on your pussy and
dogs,
peanut butter,
your ball sack dogs looking up the
peanut butter.
I mean like come on,
you have to be so fucking,
you have to be so out of options to make
your dog lick your ass,
lick your nuts and your asshole.
Just go hire a human hiring human.
It's a lot of people that are really
desperate,
you know,
like you think about it,
the human touch like touch from person
is mandatory like people need it is a
requirement like vitamin C and it's just
a requirement that your body needs.
But there's a lot of people that just
don't get it.
I know,
I never knew how were,
how much of a requirement was until when
I first moved to La.
When I first moved to La,
uh,
I moved from La,
from New York to La.
Didn't know anyone out here didn't have
any friends.
And I was on this set and uh,
I'm doing this TV show and I was there
for like a couple of weeks and I guess I
hadn't hugged anybody or done,
touched anybody in a couple of weeks.
And this girl and set gave me a hug,
just gave me a hug and it was like,
oh.
It was like I got filled up with like
affection and love.
Ah,
that's just real.
But it was,
it was the weirdest,
like I had never experienced that before
because,
you know,
I always had a girlfriend or always had
friends that it was always some sort of
physical contact.
Right.
But out here you were alone.
I was alone.
And then when this girl hugged me,
I was like,
and I remember never forgetting and I'm
like,
wow,
that was a weird moment.
Like that's a,
that's a physical requirement.
Like when that girl hugged me,
my body was like,
yes,
this is what we need.
It like,
Whoa,
like when you're thirsty and you get a
glass of water,
you're like,
ah.
That's what it was like when she hugged
me and it wasn't even the sexual thing.
It was just a human affection.
Yeah.
Well that's why.
That's why they say kids that don't get
touched when they're young get like
that.
Don't get hugged or any affection that
grew up so fucked up mentally.
It the part of your brain doesn't
develop that,
that,
that meeting,
that chemical react cause the transfer
of chemicals skin to skin.
That's like such a big deal for the
development of your brain.
So when kids don't get it,
it fucking ruins then.
Yeah.
They say that about babies and
orphanages.
The babies in orphanages,
they don't get,
they don't get it.
They die.
They can literally die from not being
held.
That's a trip.
Meanwhile,
animals just fucking put their kids out
in like,
go get the fuck outta here.
Get the kick them out of their nest.
The the fuck face learning to fly.
He ever seen those birds that fall off
cliffs who showed us that was at
sturgeon now I think I did.
I think it was last time I was here.
I think it was you.
Yeah.
The birds that fall just to see if they
can stay alive.
The rocks and half of them die.
Before I came on,
I saw that class.
Right.
That was fucked up.
This is a lot of like dark shit in the,
in the animal community.
You think about the survival of these
little beasts.
Absurd.
I was just reading about how many deer
every year freeze to death in Idaho.
Don't ask me why,
but that was,
I was reading,
it's thousands.
It's like sometimes these,
they'd lose thousands of animals.
Even tried to migrate somewhere else
that you may have made up.
Those numbers might be hundreds.
It's like six.
It's a lot.
That's a lot.
They call it winter kill and when they
have a hard winter,
like a real hard winter and it was
hundreds and hundreds animals this dead
frozen to death.
Like imagine living in a place where you
barely make it.
Like cryogenics right?
When you go to crowd healthcare in,
your legs are shaking and you get out of
there at three minutes and 40 seconds to
someone stays in there to six and they
just become an ice cube.
That's fucking insane.
That's what you live.
You don't have a house,
your stupid fucking deer wandering
around through the woods.
That's it.
That's your life to get eaten.
That's like back in,
back in the Midwest.
Uh,
they would send out those flyers all the
time for a registered gun owners to go
hunt.
Cause the overpopulation of the deer,
it was so bad that they would die or
that they would try to eat each other,
which is crazy.
It's turning the cannibals.
But yeah,
cause there wasn't a food,
you know,
so there was overpopulation.
It wasn't a food down enough landmass.
They would try to eat each other.
Christ.
I'd never heard of that.
But they'd get,
they'd get a,
they'd pay,
they would,
you know,
they would give you incentive to go to
go hunt if you were,
you know,
a hunter to go take care of some of the
deer.
Well there's two options.
Either you hunt them or you bring in
something else.
That anthem,
that second option is always a bigger
problem.
Way bigger problem.
Then you change the change,
the whole makeup of it.
Yeah.
Well,
California is kind of done that.
California has done a weird thing
because every other state manages their
Predator population.
California,
you can bear hunt in California,
but you can't do it in any effective
way.
What that means is like there's two ways
that are really effective ways to hunt
bears.
One is over bait,
so you would like leave some food down
and you'd wait in like a blind and hide
in the bear would come to get the food
because otherwise the places where bears
live,
they don't live in a open country.
They hide and they smell everything.
They smell you miles away,
like literally miles away.
If the wind is at your back and the wind
blows across a valley in a is two miles
away,
he'll go like,
he'll know you there.
And that's not even a joke.
I mean it's a different kind of thing.
And then on top of that,
the here way better than you can
imagine.
And they see pretty good too.
So you're fucked.
Like you're not going to find right.
So they have a bear,
they'd have bear hunting and California,
but it's very ineffective.
Like most people don't,
don't,
you can't put bait,
I mean it was just had to be
circumstance that you found.
Yeah.
The only other place is where,
um,
you can hunt bears effectively and it's
not over bait are areas where there's
like wide open spaces or um,
these cut blocks would,
a cut block is where a lumber
company comes in and chops down trees
and then these little roots grow up and
he's little tiny saplings and stuff.
And the bears like to come in and eat
those.
And meadows like peep.
So people go to meadows and occasionally
you'll spot a bear there,
but the does its Predator control.
And then the other thing is I'm with
dogs.
The dog one is very problematic because
people don't like that.
Look,
the idea of dogs bang up a bear,
a tree and then you shoot it out of a
tree.
It just seems really fucked up.
Right.
That makes sense to me.
Um,
the mount line one is another one.
Like they stopped all mountain lion
hunting in this state and I just
decided,
no,
not going extinct.
Now,
this is a lot of mountain lions.
Why they,
why they want to get rid of it?
It's a political thing.
Same thing is a,
there's a grizzly bear ban in British
Columbia that you can't hunt grizzly
bears in British Columbia,
but they have a lot of grizzly bears.
It's like it's a real problem,
but it was,
there was a ban that was put together by
animal rights activists and then signed
by,
it was really just a few thousand people
that took like an email poll and then
they pass this 75% of them and now now
they're going to have a real problem
with grizzly bears because the people
that passed this,
they all live in Vancouver.
Vancouver is beautiful.
It's,
it's a city metro area.
There's no grizzly bears,
but those other people that live like
north,
you go like four hours past Vancouver
and these people live in the forest.
They have giant 10 foot monsters that
eat cows that live in their fucking
woods.
And you just said,
you just made it illegal to shoot the
monsters.
Right.
And you don't even live around the
monsters.
You don't even know what the fuck you're
doing.
You're in a high rise.
Also,
where those people live,
you can shoot as many wolves as you
want,
so it's gotten so bad up there with
wolves.
You could shoot a hundred wolves a day
and every day we need,
the more they want you to give you money
for it,
and some cases get up and shoot Wolfe's.
Holy Shit.
Let's go shoot some fucking Wolfe's.
Dude.
I don't want to be around wolves that
need to be shot.
I want to be,
or I want to be around wolves where
there's a healthy population where I
don't have to do anything.
Right.
The last thing you want to do is be
around wolves where there's so many
wolves,
they have to shoot him.
That's when shit gets sketch.
Yeah.
That's when it gets,
when they come after you,
that's,
yeah.
That's when there's a fucked up.
There's a balance.
There's an issue and that that's what
happens if everybody's like,
well,
leave.
Landon was Lou and they control their
own population.
Yes,
you're correct,
but it'll take 30 years.
Are you willing to see this
overpopulation of grizzly pairs
attacking wildlife,
attacking people,
attacking dogs,
and breaking into people's houses
because that will happen.
And will we include coaching in their
land?
Sort of.
But guess what?
If they find out where our food is there
going to encroach into land tissue like
there's no do we have no land and just
give up.
Give up your house,
man.
You know,
what is this like?
What are you doing when people don't
have a realistic idea of what animal
life is like?
Animal Life is beautiful,
but it's also life with its own ideas
about survival and what he wants to do.
And if you don't manage the predators,
you're not going to have the other
animals.
You're not going to have the deer.
You're not going to have the moves.
Totally.
You've got to manage everything and
biologists know how to do it.
But then we get
involved.
Like,
man,
I just do want to see the barest dime
man.
People were talking about bringing bears
back to California.
It's crazy.
Fucking shipping him.
Embarrass.
Yes,
ship.
Amen.
Well,
we have a grizzly bear on our state.
Flag.
Yeah,
no,
but the last grizzly bear was shot and
killed in Lubbock,
California.
There's a city,
well,
I don't know if it was kids that like
back up north.
Yeah,
like near Bakersfield on the way to
Bakersfield and it was a,
I think the dude's name was steven the
back.
See if you could find a l.
E,
b,
e c I believe he was the last man in
California to be killed by a grizzly
bear and they want it.
That's a wrap there.
Peter.
Lubeck,
Peter Lubbock and killed by aspects
bear.
What is that?
What it says x bear?
I think a x bear by x bear.
I think that's like a space that's like
a cross like well site because it's not
totally an ex.
October 17th,
1837 wow.
1837 and that's when they just went hog
and just killed all the bears.
They had a huge bears in California too.
They were like coastal brown bears,
like the kind they have in Alaska.
Those enormous ones you see like they
look like buses.
That's what they had here.
What are the,
what was it Kodiak?
Kodiak,
Kodiak?
Yeah.
That's a weird place.
What does this,
the Mr Peter Lubbock and the x bear.
Oh,
so it was the did call it the x bear.
I wonder why they call it the x bear.
Okay.
So it was a out in Lubbock,
cause it's now it says it's now fort to
hone where's the four off of the,
uh,
off of the five.
It was at the time it says just the
wiles of the tach p mountains,
which by the way is the exact same area
from their worldly blood.
Where a Daniel Day Lewis,
that movie there will be blood.
Yeah.
That's the,
that's where they scored oil.
That's right.
It's out in that area.
Is that him right there?
That's his homeboy homeboy that got
jacked.
No,
that's,
that's to turn it Robert Williams.
And what does Williamson leading a
government expedition and pass through
Santa Clarita in 1853 as a part of an
effort to find a practical route for a
transcontinental railroad.
And then,
and then they found bears 1853 he noted
an unusually large number of grizzly
bears in the area.
There's a lot of pair share.
Oh boy.
Okay.
Well hold on.
Sub Sub.
Sub.
Scroll down.
It says party left by Fitzgerald beal,
Lieutenant Edward Fitzgerald,
Bill Commissioner,
the Indian affairs at the time found the
Lubeck tree a tree in 1854 okay,
so it's a tree where the,
they like had something that they left
to market.
This is by 1890 the tree bark had grown
over and cover the Lubeck inscription.
Yeah,
so there was a,
there was a tree that was wine that like
had written on it.
This is the where the body was remained
the remains of a man approximately six
feet tall who was missing his right
forearm,
both feet and his left hand along with
two broken ribs and left side.
All consistent with a gruesome bear
attack.
Yeah,
baby [inaudible].
So that's what they did when they had
these bears in California.
They were just jacking people.
So they killed them all.
Like they literally have no bears left.
Not just in California,
but there's brown bears.
But no,
no grizzly bears.
Brown bears are much smaller.
Bare.
There's not only are they not in
California,
like I don't even think they're close to
California kid hair along its back and
shoulders appeared to form an ex.
Uh,
it's a common exper what,
where's,
where's all the grizzlies and the candor
all north?
Yeah.
You got to go to like,
I think if I'm correct,
I don't think you can find them until
you get to like British Columbia.
I don't think they're even in Washington
state.
I think they have them in Idaho.
They have them in Wyoming.
They're starting to find them in
Colorado.
In fact,
my friend Adam Green tree,
the guy was shot that bull up there,
that giant buffalo water buffalo and the
top of the flag,
that dude for spotted and filmed them
in,
I think the San Juan Mountains.
I think that's where it is.
I think that's the name of the range in
Colorado where people are saying there's
no grizzly bears.
But he found one hit a video of it.
He's like,
that is all fucking grizzly bear because
he's from Australia.
Fuck King.
That's how he talks.
Which state has the most grizzly bears?
Um,
600 more live of 1500 left in the lower
48 states that you have about 800 live
in Montana.
She say they gotta be up there 600 more
live in Wyoming.
He had left and there's an estimated 70
a hundred living in northern and eastern
Idaho.
Okay.
So I was right.
And two of them in Texas for some
reason,
but they're in a,
they're in Colorado now.
Adam is right a guarantees,
right?
Because first of all,
Colorado borders Wyoming and it borders
a lot of what that area is like.
What,
what,
what's on the edges of Colorado.
I know Wyoming's on one side,
I guarantee you they've crossed in
because,
well,
Utah Biologists or they're questioning
this,
the validity of this.
But Adam has been around bears.
Not only is he been around bears,
he's filmed himself getting charged with
bears while he's holding up a pistol and
put it on instagram.
He was on a 28 day back country hunt in
a,
so what do we got here?
Colorado.
What's off to the left as Utah,
Utah,
one side,
there's no bearing on the top.
Yeah.
So they come down from the top man.
Guarantee you.
Yeah,
Fort Collins is right there.
I guarantee you there's some grizzly
bears there.
Adam knows.
The point is,
this is not like a like me,
if I went into the woods and other dude
is,
oh grizzly bear,
don't listen to me.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about.
He,
he knows,
he knows.
He's sure he can see one.
You know a mile away.
Look at it through a spotting scope and
say,
that is a grizzly bear,
right where I can't.
I go,
it's a fucking bear.
It's big ass to pick.
There might be a big brown bear,
but he was positive.
It was a grizzly bear.
He said about big fucking Grizzly,
Ken Baisley.
But people have other people spotted
them too.
And people have called bullshit on him,
but there he is right there.
This is him.
Hold up the pistol and you see bite by
that tree to the left of that train.
The fog in the distance.
That's a fucking bear.
Standing at a time.
Legs.
Watch this.
See it.
See it standing in the fuck you.
Indeed.
The thing rushed him three or four
times.
Now here's where it gets crazy.
He had a gun but the gun had the wrong
size bullets and he didn't even know it,
but it was jammed.
So even though he thinks that he would
be able to shoot that bear,
he really wouldn't be able to because
the bullet isn't even in the fucking
chamber.
Look at that 300,
4,000 views.
I think that was in uh,
believe that was an Idaho.
No.
Youdo you think that was an,
I know that's where he was.
And then here's the other big thing.
You shoot that fucking thing and you
know you're in real big trouble.
You have to prove that that thing was
trying to kill you.
If you had video,
that's fucking amazing.
Yeah,
he did this.
One of the reasons why I filmed it,
to let it,
cause he had been charged,
bluff charged a few times.
I'd run up to within stop.
It's always a woman with her babies.
Like she's just trying to,
and a woman,
female bear with their babies.
She's trying to protect these bitches.
Are Bears fucking charging me and said,
mama trying to protect her cubs.
I get it that the dudes don't do that.
They won't charge now.
They just hate you.
They'll fuck you up.
Yeah.
If a dude is charging you,
you're fucked.
Really hungry.
Just want you to go with that.
Most of the time the males are just run
away in the less and less,
um,
you kill something and then it decides
to take it from you.
Like if you kill a deer and it's wants
it,
yep.
You better let it fucking have it.
You have to fuck off.
Well,
in certain places you have to like,
you're not even allowed to scare them
off,
I think.
I mean,
I would let them dates.
There's some states it might be Montana.
No,
there's some,
it might be Wyoming,
Wyoming.
Maybe there's one state where once you
shoot something,
if it might be Idaho,
it's one of those states we just keep
jumping and keep jumping.
They could be North Dakota.
If a bear finds your your meat,
you have to leave it alone.
You have to leave the bear with your
meat.
You have to give up.
I mean,
well,
who?
Who's fighting that?
Yeah.
I would let that shit go.
Most dudes,
I bet at that bit they'll shoot that
thing,
shoot the bear.
Just because how hard it is to,
if you're on a back country hunt and
you,
you finally get a deer.
You know how hard that is to do.
It's so hard.
It's going to be like circle of life
type of shit where you're like,
man,
I fucking,
I'm in.
You know what I mean?
Boom.
You're in their restaurant.
Fuck you.
Yeah.
It's Meegan Sam.
Fuck you in the Dick.
I just wouldn't go to a place they
wouldn't let you scare off a prison.
I don't want to go to a place that has
them.
See,
that's my shit.
I'm not.
No,
thanks.
Yeah.
I only bird on him when I was a kid
burden directly.
I did dear,
but a bird hunted a lot when I was a
kid.
My Dad loved bird hunting.
The thing about deer,
and I mean even bird hunting,
it's like if you're in the right place,
you could run into a wolf or a bear.
You could if you kill a bear in
defensive license,
life and property,
barris killed in defensive life and
property belonged to the state.
If you kill a bear,
you must remove the hide from the
carcass and also salvage the skull.
By the way,
that happened to my friend Cam Haynes.
He,
this is a crazy bears are bro.
He shot a bear with a bow
and Arrow killed it and then another
bear claimed the body and start a
burring it,
this female bear.
Holy Shit just decided as mine,
I'm gonna eat this.
And because they cannibalize each other,
totally.
Hundred percent of the time,
100% of all bears are cannibals.
They just all kind of one bears dead.
The other ones to start eating it,
babies,
they start eating it.
This is how fucked up it is.
My Buddy lives in Alberta and uh,
his son watched a bear kill a cub and
then watched the mom eat the baby.
Oh fuck.
That's crazy.
Like the mom chased the,
the bear off that killed the cub and
then she ate it.
Yeah.
Well cause it's dead at that point.
Was she going to do?
But it's just what patrician yeah.
That is what it is.
I mean,
that's literally how they,
that's,
that's how they roll up there.
You've never looked at your kid and been
like,
I ain't even fucking eat my kid.
Look good part.
What part would you eat first?
Uh,
for the fat,
whatever the fattiest is.
You know what I mean?
Just pop the legs off.
I mean,
when you're down to that point,
like if you're in like one of them,
uh,
situations like the,
like,
like a,
like a movie life crap.
Yeah.
They crashing and he's alive.
Like when you start eating,
people do,
do you look for the place where you jump
off first?
Like once you get to the point where
you're like,
[inaudible] get about eating each other.
I'm killing myself.
Yeah.
I'll probably jumping off a cliff
jumping.
I'm not he unwanted.
You fucking people,
man.
People who would walk up,
bro.
But there's some places where you're
just not walking out.
Okay.
You better get that out of your head
because you don't have any food.
Yeah.
There's no water.
There's nothing.
Nope.
You're not going to make it get it's a
lot at the real guys.
Wow.
That's crazy.
It was soccer team,
right?
Yeah,
and so they ate dudes who died.
Is this when they rescued him?
They took pictures of him.
That what it is that has them going back
to the scene.
They look very happy.
They look happy.
It must,
they must have been rescued.
That's crazy shit.
Is that the movie?
That's the movie as the bull show is.
What's the real image?
I asked the real image.
Wow.
That's fucked man.
Chill.
Imagine how long did they live up there
for?
72 days says,
oh Jesus,
that's a long time to be people.
You know.
You get old too.
You'd be like this guys.
Fingers don't taste good and they're
eating everything frozen too.
I don't even know if they could make
fires.
They're scooping like the using a spoon
to scoop your asshole out.
What did they,
they use your bottle as a fucking bowl.
They're just putting stuff in your
bottle as a bolt.
They figured out fire like how to make a
fire up there or what would they do?
I think they did.
What would they even burn?
Middle of.
Oh Wow,
this is a real bodies now you keep
showing us pictures of the movie,
but what would they burn?
They burn whatever's inside that plane
leftover like clothes,
shirts.
That would go quick.
You've got to find some woods.
You've got to find some trees.
There's nothing up there.
If they're way above the timberline.
Yeah.
And probably a bunch of people broken up
there.
Probably a bad backs and fucked up while
they're all fucked up on the accident
that she,
I remember that movie was so fucked up.
It's a,
it's a terrifying thing.
Well,
thousand feet altitude to wait 12,000,
11,008.
That's like literally
just above the tail or no,
no,
no.
Timberline is like 13,
five or something.
You know what they give you when you
have altitude sickness and you're at
that height?
Cialis.
So boner pills,
boner pills.
They want to get hard,
so you just don't get it.
Models,
boner pills.
They give you a bottle of skiing down
the hill,
which is a fucking hard dick.
The,
um,
what those things do is dilate.
They dilate your muscles and apparently
that helps you breathe easier when
you're at high altitude it.
Well it definitely does because they
have like we go to breckenridge every
year,
we have family up there and uh,
we sleep there house is uh,
you know,
halfway up the side mountain we sleep at
about 11 to 11,000,
200 feet.
That's,
that takes a while to adapt to not easy.
Well if we go to Denver for three or
four days,
but three days beforehand you get it a
little easier,
you get a little bump easier.
But I'm not,
what else is not just there's,
there's another one that's just that
almost the same kind of a breakfast,
one of the highest out there.
But yeah,
we sleep at like 11 to like 10.
It's like anywhere from 10,
10,
seven right out,
right near like near the house and then
till like 11,
two is where it usually ends up cause
I've got my altimeter on my phone.
I'm always like,
I wonder how high.
Yeah,
I use one of those two.
I just want to,
I was like no one and doesn't have work.
Even if you don't have service.
Yeah.
How's that work?
Well,
do the things are still sending data
even if you don't have service GPS?
Yeah.
We've just accepted that the
government's tracking us.
Right.
I'm fine with it.
We'll do it.
When this thing,
when I first got to Japan,
the first thing that I did,
I was like,
hello?
Yeah.
It flips over and it tells you exactly
where you are without,
there was no service on it.
It was like poop pinpoint that Google
maps was like,
oop,
you're right there.
Whoa.
This is a trip,
dude.
It's never not sending and receiving
data.
Right.
Constantly been on airplane mode.
Still sending and receiving data.
Well,
I knew this lady used to work for CNN
and when she would go to places,
um,
if they,
if you had an iphone,
like she would go to these Middle
Eastern places.
Do they have to talk to people and
interview them?
They would take your phone away if you
had an iphone,
if you had an android phone,
they take the battery out.
And the olden days.
Right.
But if you had an iphone,
they just say,
no,
we're taking that phone shit.
You're being tracked and listened to
100% period.
You're in some fucking bow rain place.
Some weird fucking,
they take away your eye,
go with your phone.
That's what she would meet with these
people.
Do you do that at shows?
By the way,
do you take away,
do you do now you do the pouch thing,
the yonder patches,
patches rather.
It's a great idea.
I've heard changes the game.
It changes the show.
It's like first of all you could always,
if you have important phone calls I have
to do is just leave the room.
The phone will ring,
you leave the room,
you open the pouch.
Once you get out of the room and you can
come back in and put it back in the
pouch,
you come back in.
So we did.
Touches are not with them that their
stretches with you.
Oh you saved the pocs.
They have the key.
Yeah.
Fronts all locked up.
Right.
And when you go out,
they opened it up like people will,
I'm not giving my phone up.
You don't have to give your phone using
your hands,
but you're in this pouch and when you go
out they open,
the pouch takes three seconds,
it opens up,
you get the phone out.
So if you'd like,
say if you have a babysitter at your
house or something like that issue you
can check it.
But in the pouch it doesn't disable the
phone from not getting service or
anything.
See that's what I think they should
figure out.
Well cause it's a public service to the
phone.
If there was an urgency though,
see that would,
that would prevent,
see what the thing is that's good about
the pouch is that if you really like,
if there's some critical issue that you
think could come up,
I know your phone's ringing like okay
I'm going to leave the drain.
But then it gives people incentive to
still have their phone on to ring.
Do you know what I mean?
That is true.
That is true to me is saying like,
you know what's true.
How often did the emergent,
if the show is two hours in an emergency
happens within that gap of time of two
hours.
Isn't that the University of Spain like
this is life.
The fuck the fuck.
What the fuck?
You have kids that nobody wants to hear
that.
No,
totally.
I get that,
but it's also like,
I just feel like,
you know,
this show is so much fucking better to
way better without the phone.
Have you done one of those shows?
No,
you should come with me.
We'll do a do a gig together.
I would love that because the idea of
it,
I thought when I heard it I was like,
that's the most brilliant shit I've ever
heard in my life.
It's phenomenal.
I'm telling you,
it's phenomenal.
I think gets people mentally in a place
where they're like,
I'm just gonna enjoy the shelf.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I don't have to fucking think about
nonsuit.
Everybody's got their phone up
everywhere you go.
They have their phone up film and
everything.
They want to film everything and want to
take pictures of everything and it's a
distraction.
I just went to go see the friend of a
friend play,
you know,
like abandoned.
Uh,
even that like small nonsense venues,
people sell their fault.
I'm not talking like,
you know,
it's like fuck it.
And you know,
a massively famous like Bruno Mars,
like every kid.
I'm sure it's like good the whole time.
Of course.
Even like a small,
tiny little venue where I was like 80
people all have their phones out too.
I thought those would just be a little
bit more chill.
I think it's less of an issue with
music,
although some people do have an issue
with it.
But I'm,
with music,
you're in,
you're the,
you already know the songs.
Yeah.
Like with jokes,
like say if you're working on a new
hour,
right?
And you go to the laugh factory and five
people in the audience are filming you
and they want to put it on youtube.
Like your,
your jokes are half Kodaly.
You're trying,
comedy is one of the weird art forms
because you have to practice it in front
of other people.
Right?
You could write it alone,
but you really don't know how it goes
together until you try it in front of
other people.
And out of all the bits that you have,
how many of them start off and they eat
dick?
Most?
Almost all of them.
There's like one or two that you do that
you right away that hits and you're
like,
oh right,
fuck yeah.
All right,
that's good.
From start desperately bad.
And to try to figure out how to make it
work somewhere.
Where the fuck is it?
You know?
And you're trying to convey that to
them.
You're like,
trust me,
this is not your,
you just haven't heard it yet.
It's just you'll hear it in a year,
come back in a year,
the [inaudible] and even then like even
when you got something down,
like sometimes I'd take a chance with
it,
like maybe I'm not totally done with
this.
We take it out on a left turn.
You're like,
Ooh,
oh,
I've talked to like stuff.
When I find that I tried once and I
hated it and like a year later and then
I tried again.
And it works.
Yeah.
That's weird.
That I love.
Yeah.
Well you don't even know why.
Like what's wrong with me then?
And write with me now.
Something about the rhythm of the way
you even thought about it.
Like I think sometimes when I get an
idea of a joke and the rhythm of the
joke,
I can't even find,
like I'm like,
I don't even know why.
I just kinda liked the idea that for
some reason and then a year or two later
you're like,
something else usually happens that
goes,
that's just like when I felt blank and
then these things kind of like Mesh
together.
It was just like the missing piece.
Well,
what's in your head is so important.
That's why Theo Vaughn so fucking funny.
It's my guy because Theo's act is like
so ridiculous.
Oh,
and when you see it,
if you saw it on paper,
there's a lot of bits that you'd see on
paper.
You how,
what does that,
that's funny.
And then you see him live,
you're like,
ah,
it's amazing.
In his head he knows why.
That's funny.
Right?
He knows why that's funny.
And then he tells it to you in the way
that it's going on in his head and you
start fucking howling.
Right.
But like if you're not totally sure if
it's funny,
which you usually aren't when you're
trying something out on stage,
they can kind of tell.
Totally.
You're not totally sure the money.
So if someone films that and then puts
it on youtube,
if that's not good,
like say me,
maybe I'm an Andrew Santino fan and I go
as new bits kind of suck.
I'm like,
no,
just say you haven't really seen him.
Yeah.
This is a,
it's an embryo.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You saw the beginning stages of what is
going to be,
yeah.
That's stuff.
That's the whole filming of,
uh,
of,
of shows.
And they still,
they bus people at the store all the
time for her trying to do that.
But there's still people that tried to
get away with it.
They UCP poking up there for just fans.
Some of them are just fans.
I would say most people are just a fan.
They just want to have that little
piece.
But I just think there's always fucking
people that are up to no good.
Well,
there's always people that are just,
first of all this people that if you're
a performer and they're not a performer,
they don't give a fuck total like
they're not,
they're not looking out for you.
They say,
Hey,
I'm fucking audience.
Whenever you worry about you,
you're doing it.
I'm a fucking guy who films I've paid to
be here,
pal.
Yeah,
that's what I do.
All right,
and you're a performer guy,
so fucking perform performer.
I film this next performer guy coming to
the stage.
You're going to love him.
Someone said this to sturgeon,
a sturgill simpson comes up to him in an
airport and sticks a fucking camera in
his face when he's talking to his friend
and his friend are talking to guys like
holding the camera.
He's like,
what are you doing man?
He was,
hey,
it's a price you pay,
bro.
Fuck what he says to them.
It's the price you pay that nothing
drives me more insane.
When people say Shit like that,
the price you pay.
I just decided that's what comes along
with the territory.
Hey attacks,
bro.
Time to pay the same tax tax.
I stand in front of you.
When you talked to your friend,
like in any other world that would be so
rude.
Like if you were just standing by
talking to your friend and both of you
are an insurance salesman and a guy came
up and put a phone in your face,
you'd be like,
what the fuck is this guy?
I'm insured by state farm so I get to do
this.
It's just price.
You pay,
you want to be in public.
I get the film yet
like that's a,
that's a thing that people have decided,
right?
Some people in their head like this guy
with a camera that if you are a famous
person,
like anything you do.
Yup,
I'm allowed to film you everywhere you
go.
I'll take pictures because he does this
because there's this big disconnect that
that people that are famous are people.
There's this thing that's like,
no,
you're ours now.
We we,
we made you famous so now you're ours.
Whatever we want from you.
That that idea is fucking crazy to me
that someone's like,
they're barely human.
Sometimes they don't treat people like
they're not human.
They're just,
you know,
it was pretty good at it.
Pretty good.
Is the TMZ guys for the most part and
they come up to with the cameras,
they're very good guys.
Like for the most part,
yeah.
A lot of them are actually comics.
They're like,
do it as a few of them.
I knew where comics that are struggling
and they meet people,
the airport and asking weird questions
and shit.
Most of the time it's no big deal.
I'll see.
I'll go cheese or Cheddar.
It's one of those kids,
they have the fucking weirdest.
Oftentimes the questions are so like,
yeah,
well they're just trying to get
something,
but that's how they're getting by,
you know?
Totally.
But it's just,
there's almost never a good idea to
answer those questions.
Oh,
did you look like a fucking idiot?
No matter what.
Like,
oh,
someone got Anthony Bordain at the
airport and they said,
if you were going to cook dinner for
Donald Trump and Kim Jong Moon,
what would you serve?
And he says,
hemlock.
And then all the magma assholes went
fucking crazy.
That's a porridge.
And he's threatening to kill the
president.
That said,
someone called the finger fair with and
juvenile arrested
fucking maggot hats,
all filled with sweat around the brim
for anything like a foot.
His hat smells like a foot going to kill
the president.
Mr Mr. Secret service agent.
I want you to rest on your birthday.
There's no joking about the pregnant.
Meanwhile all he does is crack jokes.
Yeah,
I wish he really did say that.
That motherfucker line while he was
president.
Come on.
I mean,
that shit would be hilarious if he did
that as president.
What would everybody do?
Go.
Oh,
you're not allowed to do that.
He wrote right now the president to not
to not cuss.
That's kind of like a,
but I think that like when he tweeted
it,
Kim Jong,
who to call him little rocket man.
That was hilarious.
So funny.
Just plain funny.
Well,
he goes,
did you see the one tweet?
He goes,
I don't know why Kim Jong Moon said I
was old.
I would never say he short and fat.
It's like a return to like comic.
Yeah.
As I go,
I don't smack that did go to your work.
It's making the exact same thing.
Yeah.
That's so funny.
But it mean the fact that he just like
this was,
this is the president saying this fuss
funny.
It's fucking hilarious.
But meanwhile,
Kim Jong Moon now wants to sign a peace
treaty.
They want to meet,
they're going to meet,
they're going to meet.
Nobody wanted to meet with him before.
Everybody's like,
just too dangerous.
So I never call him,
showed him fat.
Oh,
whenever I tried so hard to be as friend
and maybe some day that'll happen.
Yes.
He,
he,
he shits on you,
shows you the consequences if you
fucking with him and then he opens up.
That's kind of what we do anyway.
That's like what friends do that you
like?
You Shit on each other and then you're
like,
dude,
I love you.
It's because I fucking,
maybe someday that will happen.
Oh well I try so hard to be his friend.
This guy.
Come on,
man,
this look I'm not,
there's a lot of things this guy does
wrong.
Fucking entertaining,
very entertaining.
There's no,
never been a more entertaining
president.
Not even close.
No.
He is the fucking grand champion of
being an entertaining for as long as he
doesn't blow us up and he gets out
without getting in the box like it's,
it's highly possible.
That doesn't make it out of this one
alive,
but if he does,
he gets through the whole thing.
I think he's going to be good.
You think so?
I think he'll be fine.
Let me,
let me say this,
the last four years or eight years and
look at all these in.
A lot of liberals are like,
what?
Never.
Whether it lasts ever trump.
If it lasts for eight years,
the one thing they'll that we will all
say,
we'll look back on.
We'll go,
man,
that's crazy.
It took that thing for us to talk about.
A lot of things like the me too movement
would have never happened.
If Hillary got in office.
Yeah it would have.
Sure.
I don't think so.
Man.
Weinstein got exposed.
That's the hardest one.
But I think we're,
we're tumble effect of what happened
with him.
I agree too,
but I think it all helped in together.
Yeah.
I,
I'm just saying like I bet you the
harvey thing wouldn't have been so real
and Hillary got in cause it cause all
the liberals that condemned all the
liberals,
like all the liberals that called out,
people like harvey and everyone in our
business,
they would have been so gleeful of this
hillary thing.
I think that would've still been like,
ah,
well we'll cover it up like we've been
doing for the [inaudible].
It's not like it just started,
it's been going on.
Why?
Why not suppress stories before because
they,
they got these people to support.
I just think the power of social media,
it's just,
I think the timing was perfect with
trump.
I think.
I'm just saying like I think,
think so.
I think those things led to it just
being like,
all right,
that's it.
We have to do something.
I think it was definitely a factor,
but I bet you it wouldn't happen so fast
with Hillary.
I bet you that would have been a longer
road.
Oh yeah,
dude.
I Dunno.
Because liberals would have gotten
exactly what they wanted.
The only way it would have been a longer
rows because Weinstein supported
Hillary's camp.
That's what I'm saying.
That is possible.
All part of the same cause there's a lot
of photos of them together.
Put Him with Obama,
but he's got photos of everybody.
Yeah.
Everybody liked him just hugging up on
all these people that call him a monster
now.
Yeah.
Things out.
He's a god.
Like Meryl Streep Saves a God.
Yeah,
a godsend.
It's a sod sense.
The same thing with trump though.
Like how many celebrities you see with
pictures of trump?
It's hysterical.
Killer.
Diehard liberals that are like,
they asked me to,
you have your parents buds and all that
shit.
They asked me to do the apprentice when
I was doing the second round of fear
factor.
When you said,
no way,
I don't want to live in New York for
three months and that's it.
My kid was one of my,
my youngest kid was very young.
Who is going to be on the show.
I don't know.
No idea.
I would have loved to see who he
would've gone up with.
Dude.
I would've been so Dennis Rodman,
non competitive.
I would have been high as fuck Cindy
Lopper time.
Oh.
To try to come up with a good idea.
And if it didn't work,
now you have a two to one.
That's why.
Cause you didn't care.
Yeah.
The people that care,
that's who,
that's who loses.
I don't know man.
I cared so little that I probably would
lose.
I think you'd win.
I probably would barely the person
that's like,
man,
I forgot.
I'm,
don't you have to be good at business.
I'm fucking terrible at business.
Like what would you,
some of the people on that show,
they just,
they're all doing it.
They don't know.
I mean that like who they cast on it.
They wing it.
It's like whoever they guess.
I've seen literally 13 seconds of that
show and it's all clips.
You're fired,
you're fired,
you're fired.
That's the best clip you're fired.
I just,
I don't get it.
I just did.
Just didn't seem like a fun show.
I wish she came at her
fired.
I would add McDonald's with you.
I don't eat that shit.
I do.
Ali,
yours.
He eats fried chicken with a fork and
knife.
Dude,
that's it.
This guy,
he's a cop.
He's a comic act.
She's a comic that he is a cartoon.
He's an odd and that's for sure.
Do you think he's gonna run again?
100% right when he was gonna win again,
100% he's going to win again.
Yeah.
Wow.
And I'm not saying like,
of course there's people that are
probably like,
fuck dude,
I just need to come to my boy hearts
gallery and same,
I never trump exhibited that was burned
to the ground by Mexicans.
How ironic.
Nazi coffee.
I just think,
I think he's going to win again.
I just do.
I think unless the Democrats can pull
something together in the next year and
a half,
two years to someone that actually is
like a formidable component.
Well my activism is going to prevent
that.
I just,
I just think he's going to go again.
He might look if he's smart and he
clearly is a very clever man.
If he's a clever man,
it's entirely possible that he's got one
round in the chamber for like right
around six to eight weeks out totally
before the election.
One thing where he like let something
happen or shit goes down and he has the
perfect solution to put out that fire
and he's good to go.
They plan that stuff,
man.
Absolutely.
People working on it right now.
The moment you get into office,
they're trying to keep you in office and
sometimes people die and it dumps all
day.
Yeah.
Sometimes people die and he's just,
hey,
we're going to do,
what does this President Johnson's
marines,
what'd he say to soldiers in the space?
He wants to create a space for us.
Oh,
what dude?
Fuck yeah.
Why did he say let's shoot up the
strategy for space recognizes that space
as a war fighting domain.
Well,
just like the land,
air and sea.
I don't like the way he says this.
He even have us.
For us.
We have the space for us with the navy
and a space for us.
So what did he does is he has a bunch of
buddies that make spaceships.
So what he's going to do is they make a
fucking deal,
mechanized deal,
mechanized deal.
We sat down and we got a nice deal and
they're going to take another $4
trillion and pump it into the space for
us.
And then they're going to,
they're all going to wear like Luke
skywalker outfit,
right?
They're all going to wear some sort of
crazy space suit that looks dope and
we're going to be all on board.
Yeah.
Space Wars for dude.
Tight give.
Imagine we start seeing like overhead,
like we're in the sky a button.
We'll look at an and the night sky and
you see like a rocket ship flying back
and forth part of that,
uh,
the tesla thing.
So cool.
It's showing the u s air force some
maneuverability thing,
whatever that was like the last hour of
the testing experiment with showing them
something that they could do that wasn't
really being talked about because the
Eli musk shooting that car in this
space.
It's so funny.
Trump must so many people nervous
and other countries like this,
like just have him talking about it.
Space war,
just as just talking to so flippantly.
I think a lot of people,
a lot of people in other countries like
him,
I think there,
I think there are hammered by his,
his just complete disregard for rules.
I think people love that.
He just doesn't give a shit.
You think so?
I think so.
Totally choose a terrified that this guy
is running America.
I think like our friends do,
but I think that the majority of the
other countries that don't give a shit
about us are like,
that guy's great.
I think our friendly countries,
you know like England,
I'm sure it's like he's a nuisance,
you know?
But I think,
I think countries don't give a fuck
about us are like,
that guy's hilarious.
That guy's a weirdo space war.
Imagine we had a space where we in
Russia.
That would be fucking awesome.
Be a great movie.
Like how do we stop a war from breaking
out who?
Who was going to stop a war from
breaking out?
Nobody took.
It seems like they just keep pushing
each other.
Like someone's going to throw a sucker
punch.
Yeah.
It's going to happen.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
And then finally they're in the fucking
hallway and they're pushing each other.
Right?
No one wants to step two,
keep hitting one or two books out of
each other's hands.
Yeah.
And it's always right there.
So always right there.
Okay.
Then finally someone takes the hit.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean,
it could easily happen with some little
banana republic.
Right?
That could start it off.
Some crazy dictator in Venezuela or some
shit could send a missile at some other
dude,
fuck him up and like,
oh bitch,
that we're doing now.
And then we backed discount and then the
Russians back,
the other guys.
And next thing you know it,
old jetson millionaire and we're in a
fucking war.
I mean,
which were so weird about war.
It's like we accept the fact that war
exists,
but only when it's not near us.
Not really interested in more.
That's clothes.
Can't be here.
Like we have war in Afghanistan.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But that's inevitable.
But war over here,
it's like,
no,
no way.
No Way.
No,
no,
you can't.
We don't.
But if we're going to have war over
here,
I hope we can contain it to like,
you know,
like North Dakota or are you somewhere
where I'm not near some weird spot.
Some spot where we're like to fight in
the middle with it and a lot of shit all
over the spot.
You can have that area go fight right
here.
Yeah.
If we flew right here would be good.
Would it be the one like we all
designated this is the place we meet.
We fuck each other up.
What state?
Connecticut.
Yeah,
for sure.
Nobody would cry.
Fuck it.
That's like,
that's like afterschool fist fights of
like a,
you are the secret garden dude.
I'm gonna fuck you up.
You know,
and you'd wait all day.
People be talking about it like you
heard about the fat ass bro,
you to go the bass pro meet me in
Connecticut.
You want to solve this the right way,
dog,
you mean Connecticut?
Oh,
I hope we don't get in a war now,
but we're in one.
Yeah,
see that's the thing.
Like we are one with some dudes who
brought goats and they live in the
mountains.
Yeah,
we're in one with those guys,
but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But this is over there.
It's just doing,
I go to starbucks every day.
I don't feel it.
I don't,
it's one of those that were at the war.
I go to him and get my Nazi coffee out
in boyle heights and I'm straight.
It's white people coffee,
weird white coffee,
wp coffee.
It's just crazy that they could just
scream,
fuck white people.
And everybody's like,
well,
you know,
they don't want to be gentrified.
No.
They'll know some of their say and
somebody saying,
I mean,
they don't want white people moving in
and opening up galleries.
You know,
what's another part of it?
This is where it gets really weird.
So I went into rabbit hole.
I started reading a lot of Isabella.
What I read was that part of it is being
hijacked by white artists that don't
like the people that own the gallery.
So they get on the side of the people
that want no gentrification and they
sabotage the gallery because they have a
personal feud with the guy who owns the
gallery does so far,
so there was a lot of that.
It was white artists that we're teaming
up against the white people.
They're teaming up on the side of the
Hispanics to get,
yeah,
Mexicans,
Latinos.
I mean,
I don't know if it's all Mexicans.
I think east side is heavy.
There's a Honduran is all,
I mean it's just that neighborhood.
It's just a,
it's generally known as a Latino
neighborhood.
Totally.
And these people want to keep it that
way,
but,
but it's just so fucked up.
Imagine if that was white people.
If Brown people were moving in and white
people,
were we going to fuck brown art and fuck
the Nazis hate racism against white
people?
We don't automatically see it as racism,
including the people that are saying
fuck white art.
Like they don't think of it as racism
because it's against the people that are
moving in that happened to be wealthy,
that can afford to buy,
totally pushing people out.
So if you say fuck white people,
it's not racist.
But the same people that agree with
that,
you know,
the same people that are like that or
like that or like the same white people
that agree with the protesting,
they're rich.
They're already up there anyway,
there's a little bit of that and there's
just,
it's convenient because they're not that
thing.
It's like I read,
um,
this one woman was tweeting that a,
here's an unpopular opinion and not at
all uncomfortable about the idea of men
being falsely accused of sexual assault
and sexual harassment.
Like that is a crazy thing to say.
Like what if it was your son would,
if it was your brother,
what was it?
What if it was your dad and they were a
good person and accused of something.
You're,
you're not,
you don't feel bad because you don't
like men.
All men suck.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
that is sexist.
But they do,
you might not think it's sexist,
but it's fucking sex.
It's hardcore sex.
If all men suck,
if all men were violent monsters,
girls,
you'd all be dead.
Right?
Okay.
You'd all be dead.
Someone along the way would have done
something terribly.
So we're not all bad.
No.
Some of us are bad men are bad and that
I want to,
I don't,
I won't even say us.
Some males of the species are bad.
Some females are bad.
Yes.
Where's that?
That's not even a part of it.
It's like people are bad.
I don't understand this whole thing.
Like all people are good.
Most people,
I think people are good,
are good,
but a lot of people are not good.
There's a lot of people.
So if there's,
like we were talking about the,
the number of,
uh,
what was the,
that weird statistic about that.
We pulled up one
out of a
0.6% what was that?
That we were just discussing?
Yes.
Micro Penis people.
Right.
So if that's how many people have a
micro penis,
how many people are fucking assholes?
Right?
More than have micro penises.
Way More.
Yeah.
So if you have a hundred people right
and 0.6 have a micro penis to are
assholes flaming assholes.
And imagine being an asshole and having
a micro penis,
you're in trouble.
You got a real pro,
you probably never developed like real
asshole tendencies cause you know,
it'd be so intimidated at someone in the
middle of a ramp,
just pull your pants down,
shut the fuck up.
And then everyone's like,
oh my God,
there's way more assholes.
But some of those assholes are women.
So like on national women's day the
other day,
like a couple people that I know
retweeted this,
someone was like believe women.
Trust women,
embrace women,
support women.
There's
some,
yes,
some are great,
some women are amazing,
some men are amazing,
some humans are amazing.
It can be amazed.
It's whole like gravitating towards one
gender specifically just because they
have a vagina or specifically just
because they have a penis is equally
stupid,
equally stupid on both sides,
and it also creates divisiveness.
Right?
It creates conflict because you were
aware us on the team penis,
that you're fully in supportive team
vagina.
That's all you're about,
right?
You're about teen vagina and you know it
was over here as a penis fan.
I'm like,
this is bullshit.
You know,
I'm willing to tolerate those vagina
fans,
but they're shitting all over paid as
this hidden tardy you shitting on penis?
I'm getting tired of it enough.
You know,
it's like Ken,
the dolphins and the raiders have a
healthy relationship amongst the fans.
Can they get together and share a
stadium together without any gang
fights?
Nothing.
Impossible.
Nope.
Not In that example.
No,
no,
but it's the same thing with team penis
versus team vagina.
Here's an unpopular opinion.
I'm not at all uncomfortable with
raiders fans getting gang raped or
stomped to death in the parking lot.
Fuck the raiders Hashtag fuck the
raiders,
right?
Yeah.
That's something a retard would say.
Write a really stupid fuck who was like
a,
uh,
you know,
anti raiders guy would say something
like that and you'd get like a hundred
likes.
Fuck gone.
Fuck all call home.
Fuck Gum.
I hate the future is female quote.
I think it's such an annoying cook.
A good luck just eating each other's
pussies.
You crazy bitches,
but we're never going to get pregnant.
It's an insane thing to say.
It's so annoying.
It's a stupid thing to say.
What are you really saying?
No one masculine.
Yeah.
Right.
Imagine what a piece of shit you'd have
to be to walk around with tee shirt.
This is the future as mass masculine
bid.
Oh No.
The future is human beings.
Hopefully we're nice to each other,
getting along,
doing each other good and being right to
one another.
We're all,
we're all important.
All of us males,
females,
everyone.
Yeah.
This whole ecosystem needs each other.
It's so funny,
but women can walk around those futures,
female shirts and not feel stupid.
That's fucking because it's a big,
if it's supported,
right,
it's,
hey,
what should we say that tell me I'm a
fucking love.
First of all,
love your shirt.
Amazing.
It's amazing.
I'm with you.
100% sister.
They can do that here,
but I'm here to tell you,
you go do that in certain parts of the
country and people are like,
fuck is that shit?
The fuck is that dog?
It's crazy when it's heterosexual women.
Can you imagine if Mensa,
Doug futures masculine,
we're just going to wrench,
we're going to be done with all this
girl short or just right.
Squirrel's suck.
Come here Steve.
Yeah,
it's stupid.
It's stupid like this.
It is general.
I mean it does like taking one gender
and deciding that's what you're really
into,
that it's just as stupid as take you one
skin color.
Totally.
Just as stupid as I am.
Really only in the dudes were over six
feet tall.
I'm six feet tall.
Should be dead.
I don't want to talk to them.
I have a team,
Marty team,
six feet.
We can always decide some new thing that
we don't like somebody about.
Right or four and so we always decide
like,
hey,
those fucking assholes from when the
town across the tracks,
like we'll have like a boundary line.
This side,
those people with them imaginary wise,
we put up a fence.
Fuck you,
fuck them,
we'll stay.
We're going to meet in the parking lot
on Saturday night and if they don't say
that we're the best,
we're going to fucking kill them.
It's and people don't see it for
whatever reason.
If you have a future is female tee shirt
on,
you don't see it that way because you
are just in support of feminism and the
support of equal rights and supportive
women doing powerful things and you
think this is a step in the right
direction,
but it's not.
No.
The future is females,
not a,
that's not a message that is good.
The future is happy,
loving people.
That's a good message.
Good.
The future is good,
honest people not not fucking hurting
each other.
People trying to do well for each other,
trying to facilitate communication and
growth and learning about each other and
tolerance like just be nice to each
other,
not the future's masculine.
Fuck off you dork.
You've fucking half a man.
You have a man.
Imagine if a guy's,
he's got the t shirt that says the
future is male.
He's a tattoo.
It's right above his dick.
He shows it sometimes.
Sometimes you could see like the top
letters because it's shaped like a,
like got a big smiley face.
It's a smile,
but it says the future's masculine.
He could see the e and the t poking out
of his underwear when he takes those
Dick route pictures.
You know those pictures of guys take
with,
they pull the pants down time.
Yeah.
You know those,
those guys,
they'll,
they'll take a picture,
they're painting the fuck runway and all
that shit right to the Dick root
sweatpants and just get back from the
gym.
Like basically showing the base of their
cock.
Cause I got the fucking,
the runners,
the fuck runner muscles.
The fuck muscles.
Yeah.
That's where Jamie's got that.
The future is masculine.
Quote.
Did you get it removed?
Second.
I need to go back.
You can't go just once.
Yeah.
It takes a long time.
Lasers above your deck has to be very
nerve wracking.
You know they make you put goggles on
when they were moving.
Tattoos,
pop,
pop.
So painful.
It's like this shoot a laser.
It's,
it looks like the most painful shit I've
ever seen in my lessons.
Crackling,
pop,
pop.
Then listen to it as,
oh it's fucking awful.
You're cooking,
you're cooking the skin,
right?
Yeah.
You have to burn it.
I knew this girl was getting this big
tattoo on her back removed and she was
at the beach and like her whole back was
like,
her lower back was this big red thing.
It was like,
it was halfway done and had like,
she had just gotten a recent,
like she had put sunscreen all over it
because it couldn't hit the sun.
Yeah.
It was like,
whoa.
What is that like?
What are you doing?
You're cooking your skin.
Do you have any tattoos?
Yeah.
Me,
I got,
I got none.
My whole arms or sleeved.
Oh yeah.
What am I thinking?
What the fuck am I talking about?
The new tattoo removal technology.
Look at,
the guy's got to get goggles on.
It's so funny.
I'm like,
you have tattoos.
I know you have tons of tattoos.
I'm not thinking cause I'm not seeing
any.
Well I'm covered up.
Yeah,
but you will often cover him up.
Well,
because they're a distraction like on
stage.
Yeah,
you do that.
He's just going over.
That's pretty amazing.
How quick it makes it disappear.
Is that new someone the other day that
was just like,
she was going over the skin and it was
not,
it didn't seem like it was harming the
untattooed so you know what they say?
It's kind of like,
um,
it looks,
it looks whoa.
That's crazy.
That is fucking crazy.
But you still have to go back a bunch.
Yeah.
Maybe you do bro.
I got one stocky.
I go once bro.
Um,
it seems like it would be amazing where,
where's that shit that was in?
This is Spa Medica,
but I don't know a,
I have a old tattoo on my shoulder that
I want to get rid of so I could finish
my right sleeve.
It says the future is masculine.
It does.
It says it all dicks spelled out with
[inaudible].
Do you know you're like you have a
picture and you look very close to the
picture.
It's really magic.
I,
it's all other pictures put together to
make it feel like a bunch of different
portraits.
All to make one portrait.
He cool?
Yeah.
You do all dicks.
You'd have to go to a master tattoo
artist.
Wow.
This guy covering his eyes.
He's got tattoos all over his face.
Holy Shit Man.
I am seeing more that than I've ever
seen in my life.
That's the new shit dude.
Wow.
Quick.
That works man.
That's incredible.
So this is a,
how old's that article?
Like new,
it's pretty new this year,
so I don't know if there's any places.
Thank you from he came me and let me get
something removed.
Gainey
you don't have any,
you've got none.
Nothing.
I think about getting something.
Nope.
Not even after this conversation.
What about the future is masculine maybe
should all get that and maybe I'll give
shit.
Yeah,
I might get that,
but I want to get it above my butt.
So when you know,
whenever there's a guy back there and
he's looking down and he can know that
I'm a support,
a dude's
help me and you bud,
you immune together with the right
ideas.
And if I've never,
I've no I,
no I can't.
I don't think I can commit
to something like that.
No,
I couldn't do it.
They're the fucking getting a tattoo to
me was always like,
hi,
I just can't,
I fucking can't do it.
I thought about it for years and then I
was like,
but every friend I had had got a bad
one.
Isn't the future is feminine sort of
like if you have a brown power tattoo,
you're allowed to have brown power.
Brown power.
Yeah.
If you had a brown power tattoo.
If you're brown person,
traditional laser does this place in
Beverly Hills,
the Pico.
Sure laser.
What does it do?
It goes,
this gone.
So you a book out
the fuck Outta here.
Bitch.
Done.
That looks pretty dope,
dude.
I might have to go get that shit done
because I've been putting off getting
this tattoo.
Who's the broad at the bottom?
I don't know.
Yeah,
she's good.
Like she's like,
Hey,
I had one about my box and uh,
they took it out.
She's a bunch of,
she had a bunch of gang stuff on her
forehead,
wants a Dick's point into my brother.
I was a kid.
I was a gang that was in a gang.
Just disappears.
I love that.
Revealing a beautiful future.
This is the real truth.
This is how it actually happens,
you know,
and I,
you know what I need in here right now.
I need a pee bucket.
I have to pee so bad.
And you're like,
hey man,
don't worry about it.
We'll talk shit about you while you're
gone.
What makes him comfortable that we talk
about,
we'll start with that.
The future is masculine.
Just makes me sad.
I get the Sun.
I'm a hypocrite though because like one
of my favorite fighters,
Cain Velasquez,
he's got brown pride tattooed on his
chest.
Never bothered me for a second.
His Dad walked here from fucking Mexico
and you know like if you're a part of a
disenfranchised community,
if you feel like you are and you have
that on,
it's like you're taking pride in
something that's considered maligned.
Right.
But I guess women would think the same
way in a more mild way that they're
disenfranchised to where are they going
to do with all their,
that tramp stamp thing that's done
right.
No,
some girls are still getting them now.
Yeah.
Really.
It's some dumb people out there bro.
Okay.
But what does the tramp stamp?
A tramp stamp is only when it's your
lower back.
Right.
But your whole back like I know a lot of
people that are getting their whole back
done.
Right.
That's,
that's,
I mean they're getting there but done
everything,
which I think is probably not the best
move.
Cause like acids look really good when
they're well formed.
Like to put,
you know what it's like.
It always seems to me what he's showing
me.
Wow.
Look at that.
God Damn,
that's gorgeous.
Look,
go back to that.
A full screen like grill below goal.
Go below.
Sorry.
There's a tiger low right that,
that screen.
Look at that one right there.
Bam.
Look at that back.
Holy Shit.
That's crazy.
That's really good work.
Who made that one?
Does it say,
I'll just says a hundred awesome back
tattoo ideas.
Yeah.
I just think,
ladies,
leave your ass alone.
Please don't get crazy.
Wow.
Like,
or if you're asked is so good,
you could tattoo the shit out of it and
still looks amazing,
but you gotta be really careful what
artists you go to.
That is the thing about tattoos.
You got to really make sure like a,
before I got my sleep,
I got my sleeves done by this guy,
Aaron Dellavedova.
Shout out to Aaron from Guru Tattoo in
San Diego.
I'd seen his work online a bunch.
I mean,
he's a real legit artist.
His work's amazing.
I knew that this guy was like super good
at tattoos,
but there's a lot of people that get
some whack ass tattoos.
I don't want to stand out.
People don't have time.
They don't have the patience to wait for
that good artist or we get nutty.
I need it today,
you know?
Do you have tattoos all over his Dick
Davies,
that one that we saw about a one
removed.
Get a better one that we know.
Have you seen they have glow in the dark
tattoos now?
Yeah.
Gotta be good for you.
Right.
Whatever.
It makes it fall on the dark.
Definitely not going to fuck you up for
the rest of your life.
It's all natural.
Yeah.
As far as we know,
if you were going to get a tattoo,
what do you think you'd get?
Yeah,
so I don't eat pride.
Yeah.
Or like,
well,
white power maybe.
Wow.
Darn Tattoos.
That's amazing.
That looks fucking cool.
Wow.
Shit.
Look it.
Look,
that's amazing.
Holy Shit Dude.
That would back up to that last one that
you just went to know what?
The girls back right there.
No to the right of that one to the right
of that one.
No,
look at that picture over the top bar
and go to the right of it.
The one that did.
That's it.
There you go.
Bam.
Look at that.
Wow.
Fuck Dude.
Yeah.
That's a good someone's arm.
Raise that someone arms.
Does that an arm?
Yeah.
Oh,
I thought it was her back.
I thought it was like leaning forward.
Buck.
That's incredible.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Then you have black lights over your
house.
Like your college again though.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Right.
Like your whole house is a college dorm.
You have to have black lights everywhere
and you have to have like a empty booze
bottles filled with like uh,
things that make them glow and shit.
Every room you go into as a college dorm
because you are the black light light
poster.
That's what I get.
Probably something to throw something
representative of Chicago back home.
Jeff fucking Chicago is a town,
a deep dish pizza in a brand,
like get a old style and a hat dog on my
shoulder.
Shit,
a snow shovel and a fucking bratwurst.
He's got a high cholesterol chart
reading everything.
He was up at the top problem,
probably fine,
but everybody's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Everyone's got affect gut and then find
and a big smile heard you make it fun.
Or Joe Rogan's making fun of us stowed
on a line.
Should in Chicago.
Tell him to fuck off.
That's what I say to Joe Rogan.
Swell.
Boycott your fucking shitty show on June
8th.
Hey is Joe Rogan Chin na Seth Rogan's to
get a browder's Joe Rogan Jay know it
and they know each other.
These different than that other guy
right in front Guy Seth Rogen,
he not fake.
Got Mad at me.
He goes,
everyone spells my name wrong cause are
you?
Sorry Dude.
Who is this?
A dumb way of spelling it.
You got to stop using an e at the end.
Rogin rock n roll again.
It's Rogan,
Rogan,
English.
Mine's Irish.
His,
his English.
Some.
Did you see this crazy soccer?
Yeah,
this is $500.
Uh,
gravity bomb.
It's a little too much for gravity bong,
but you just smoke a joint.
$500 for gravity bong.
But I look at it,
it looks crazy.
Yeah.
Shares with a real good idea.
Look,
we were joint
wash and flipped it.
Look at a flips a shit.
Right.
Upside down.
Lighter.
Yeah.
Gas Station.
Lighter joint.
Oh,
we're good.
You don't need a $500 bond.
Seth Rogan so serious.
I handed him stoner of the year award
once one of the high times awards,
500 bucks out of the wood.
That's ridiculous.
People are always trying to give me
these fucking things.
Did you get stoner of the year award?
Yeah,
I got it once right.
Did I get it?
They were offering it to me.
I think I might have had to go to get
it.
As you said,
you probably were like,
I can't go man.
Yeah.
I'm Muslim gun and go.
I'm not going to say I can't go.
I hosted the doobies one year,
which was fun.
It was like an award show that was in
like 2001 yeah.
And then,
uh,
I gave an award to seth rogen and
another time,
but they've asked me to perform at those
before and I did it once.
Where the doobies it's just everyone's
high as a kite.
It's all weird.
It's this,
I mean you just,
there's so out of it.
Crazy show ever.
It's the underground comedy show in
Toronto.
Do you haven't done that place dude,
they have a bong shop and in the back
room it's all a comedy show,
but it's all people smoking pot in the
room.
It's a hot button while you're doing the
show.
Yeah,
they have bongs on the tables,
dude.
People are blitzkrieg.
You are so high when you're on stage,
you can't remember what you were talking
about three seconds ago.
I mean it's so bad and it's thick.
Like smoke everywhere.
Like the hope,
there's no ventilation kit to material.
You just have to go fuck around.
Yeah.
I mean you could try to do material.
I definitely have tried,
but like I took Tripoli there and aaa
doesn't really get high.
Um,
at least he didn't.
I don't know.
I don't think he does time.
I think he might've been sober,
but dude,
he got blitzkrieg just breathing the air
in this place.
Fucking ripped the whole,
the whole place is bomb was,
I don't think it was a,
I don't think anyone bombed Syria bomb
venue where you're like,
I'm never going to do well in here.
They don't fucking,
they're not paying attention.
You're just out of it.
It's just the whole thing.
You're off,
everything's off.
Right.
You're so hot.
But that's also where I did a thing on
the iron sheik came on stage and that
place you ever seen that video of the
iron cheek?
Joe Rogan's and he starts talking to me
and that's when I realized the price
that pro wrestlers pay,
like the health,
like this poor fellows in crutches and
shit.
He could barely walk.
That's him and me on stage.
Fuck Joe Rogan chocolates.
Sparkling three stolen gutter quarter
Roman or you have the toughest sport in
the Olympics is freestyle wrestling
serve.
I'm so nerdy
because he know to you.
I didn't know how to change
lights
of my life being on stage.
Hi is giraffe pussy talking to the iron
cheek in a room with a pot leaf behind
me.
That's a big old pot leaf.
Was He ripped him sober?
I in the house.
There was no one sober in that place.
I don't,
I literally don't think it would be
possible to be sober in that room.
I just don't think you could be.
There's no air in that room.
They trap you.
Yeah,
I like all the fire.
There's fire like the little candles and
stuff on a table and like it's running
an air.
They don't have any air to stay lit.
The flame is flickering out so we didn't
smoke in here.
Everybody's like lists like the whole
August lights,
candles burn on weed.
Joe.
It's fine.
But the shows,
they're always real weird.
People go there and just,
it's in Vancouver?
No,
it's Toronto.
Toronto,
Toronto.
I forget what it's called.
Comedy underground or something like
that.
Puff Puff Mama around comedy club.
Underground comedy club.
Yeah.
We've done it a couple of times and he's
still doing shows and shit there.
I don't know.
They think so.
Yeah.
They don't give up.
They forgot every time they get to high,
they forgot they got through high.
We had to stop it,
but we didn't remember.
Dude,
who's coming up there?
Give them a plug.
Underground comedy Puff Mama.
Dot.
Ca.
There you go.
Fun Fun place though.
And very,
very nice people did it a few times.
Dope.
And they did tell a bunch of people that
I was coming and it wasn't coming and
then people got mad at me and I'm like,
Hey,
Yay.
I didn't fucking say I was coming.
Somebody set up a fund in there
somewhere.
Promotes your shit and you're like,
did I say it or did you hear it from
another party?
He didn't hear me promising you fucking
boom.
What you going to be there bro?
We got tickets.
Told the truth before.
Joel,
get tickets.
Your ruler boys.
Hey,
just so many people,
there's just so many people in the
world.
Where's your least favorite spot to
perform?
I don't really have one.
There's not like a city,
but what's your like,
what's the least ideal situation?
Much on the tag out a city.
I mean like least ideal is always a late
show on a Friday night in a place where
people are dumb,
right?
And they're dumb.
And then if rock,
but I'll tell you what man,
there is places that you go that don't
get a lot of love and then when you go
there,
the fucking chills are awesome.
Like Bakersfield was awesome.
Really just did it.
Just did it a couple of weeks ago.
It was fucking amazing.
They were incredible.
They were one of the,
one of the best audiences ever.
Lively,
fun by the way.
Same place to hatch.
Be Mountains.
That's right near where the guy killed
by a bear.
There will be blood.
Hi,
drink your milkshake.
That was right there.
There was that whole area.
Those people are fucking great.
They were cool.
They were really cool that you were
surprised.
You sound like you're surprised.
I'm like,
I got to give it a try.
I sought and beat burned.
I talked about on a podcast like two
years ago.
Oh,
we should do just to of tour of places
where people
don't want to go.
And I'm like,
yeah,
that'd be kind of fun.
He and I talked about doing it and we're
going to talk about doing it in
Bakersfield and we never get around to
doing it.
And so I said,
ah,
I'm just gonna go by myself.
So I decided to go.
I had a great fucking time.
It was fun.
Yeah,
we know those people deserve comedy too.
Like it's so funny.
It's like big cities.
That's why when you go somewhere small,
most of the time they appreciate it more
cause they're like,
dude,
no one ever comes through here.
You know what else is great?
Fresno.
Yeah.
For,
I'd never been there and done.
That was great.
Fucking fun,
man.
Did two shows in Fresno had a great
time.
You have no idea how many people right
now in fresno and losing their minds.
Know Fresno has some serious soul food,
some legit shit for real soul food
festivals.
How far?
I wish I could remember the place.
I got the name of the place somewhere on
my phone.
How far is Fresno from here?
It took a solid four hour drive.
Yeah.
It's almost a San Francisco,
right?
I'm a little surprised to an hour and a
half,
so
yeah,
it's about about four hours drive.
I forget the name of this fucking place.
There was a soul food place in Fresno,
not gonna be able to find it.
See if you can google soul food in
Fresno.
It's one about the highly ranked rest is
not a lot of choices in Fresno for food
chef Paul's or dolls kitchen.
I think it's chef Paul's.
Can you see if you can find a picture of
it?
4.6 yeah,
that's the spot.
It is.
Chef Paul's got to be a four point next
baby.
They had dude,
they have oxtails.
They have love.
I've sale.
That is the place.
Cool artwork on the wall.
That place,
if you are in a near Fresno,
if you're like an hour outside of Fresno
drive there.
If you're on your way,
you're passing through and you got to
ask probably not something we,
their little shrimp Gumbo,
dude,
they had chicken and waffles.
They had ribs.
I had tried tip.
They had a catfish.
I believe they had the,
but the braised oxtail was all love
sharks.
Tail man.
So good man.
They had Collard Greens.
That was amazing.
They had braised cabbage.
That was sensational.
It's a serious joint.
It's one of those places where,
uh,
one of the main things that they serve
to drink it's Koolaid and I went off the
reservation,
so I'm like,
fuck it,
I'm eating this stuff.
I might as well just have a Koolaid as
it was wonderful having some,
some ribs and a Koolaid.
There's a koolaid right there,
baby.
Having some ribs and a Koolaid.
We went there two days in a row.
That's credible.
When you go there,
you can't fucking,
you can't like health it out.
You got to go.
Go for cog.
You got to go whole hog.
If you're going to chef Paul's.
So shout out to chef Paul's cafe in
Fresno.
Good spot.
But I,
you know what man,
I'm,
I'm having a good time doing standup.
So everywhere I'm going,
I'm having fun.
I mean even when you go to a weird
place,
it's like,
yeah,
it's weirder.
I mean it's not Anaheim,
but it's weird.
You know,
it's fun.
It's not the Irvine Improv,
right,
right.
Now,
see,
I'm at a level where I'm still hustling
through places that are just,
you know,
I'm,
I'm having fun for a lot of places,
but some places I'm just
like,
the crowds are not that good.
I don't draw enough people.
So it's like,
uh,
it's,
it's hard.
I think bird talked about it.
I don't know if he talked about it here,
but he said like killing to the abyss.
He's like,
there's a part in your career when
you're killing to the abyss,
when you're kinda like,
you're,
you know,
you're a pro,
you are a professional,
you've had accolades in the game,
you've done well enough,
but your fan base isn't huge enough to
where you have a big following.
So when you go somewhere,
you crush and you'll hear afterwards
someone go,
you know,
I've never even heard of you and we,
you're one of our favorite comics now.
And they do that.
They do this thing where they're like,
we fucking love you.
Oh,
I can't believe we're going to find,
so you make these new fans,
it's great,
but it's just like you are,
you are working so hard,
crushing to 30 people to,
you know,
to earn,
earn,
you know,
to earn.
You're earning all these audiences.
Those times though,
man,
when you look back you will remember
those very fondly.
Well I can't forget them cause a lot of
them are painful a shit.
Yeah,
there's going to be rough ones.
But those are fucking so critical for
the development of your APP.
Oh to it's worth.
It's worth every and the,
and the other thing is the places that I
have built,
audiences that I love,
like Denver,
when I go back to comedy works,
I can sell that plays out because I
built an audience,
right?
Like if I build audiences in places that
really loved me,
that's the best part about going to
places where I'm like,
you know,
she,
they just show me so much love there
that you're like,
God,
that's what it is.
That's what it feels good.
Think of like if you're in a place like
Denver,
how many of those people that come to
see you are actually going to leave
comments or tweet at you?
And how many of them are just gonna
enjoy it?
Because most of the time when I go to
see somebody I just enjoy.
I just enjoy it too.
It's very rare that I say,
hey,
you have to go see this guy.
Hey,
this girl's here or this band or
whatever it is.
It's very rare,
right?
Most of the time I just enjoy it.
So like you think about you're doing
thousands of people,
right?
You're doing 200 was at 300 seats.
How much just,
yeah,
so like 300 seats you doing 1200 in the
two days,
you know,
and then you're going back again,
do another 12 they'll tell their
friends,
people come back,
tickets go quicker next time,
and then a year later.
I mean that's,
that's the key to building the road.
Like to this day,
there's places where I sell out wayne
advance and there's other places where I
haven't really haven't been going that
often.
And it's more of a difficulty to sell
tickets because you've built up a yeah,
I mean how Austin Houston's a spot where
I could just,
I sell on Houston.
I've been selling out comedy clubs in
Houston since the 90s yeah.
It's like,
it's always been a spot that I could
cause that was like for me,
Houston was one of the,
there was a few cities where legends
came from and Houston was wearing,
Kennison came from and for me it's like
Kennison and Hex Bolt came out of
Houston.
So for me it's like I had to get to
Houston and like there's this thought in
my head like I knew about the laugh stop
and river oaks.
It's one spot.
There was the nineties I got,
I got to get to that club.
Like that's the spot,
right.
There's a fucking perfect comedy club to
you.
You never worked there,
Huh?
Who's gone before he came around?
I was going to say,
but I've,
but I've listened to many albums where
they are at the laugh stop introducing
comic mind from 1999.
Yeah,
I'm from,
I'm going to be dead.
Some Warner brothers.
That was from the last stop.
I did it in Houston.
I filmed in like a recorded it rather 98
or 99 and it was um,
the perfect club.
It was perfect.
They had an open mic night,
so they had a bar in the front and they
had stage in the,
in the front and they had open Mike
night.
They would start at eight and go two
o'clock in the fucking morning and no
hacks.
I'm telling you know,
hacks and they would ostracize hacks,
boot him out of the community.
They're all artists.
There was a lot of really good comics
that came out of that.
It's wild.
And one club went under,
this one club went under and the whole
scene took a big hit.
Apparently the scenes bouncing back now
and there's,
there's a lot more comics now in
Houston,
but dude,
when I used to work there in the 90s you
would go there and these opening acts,
these guys who were working there would
be fucking killers.
They were killed.
Hers would rip.
They were great.
They were real comics.
There were real comics and then the open
Mike night you would see funny comics
that were learning how to do comedy,
like people that really have shot,
but it was just one club.
That's always a problem when there's one
club in a town.
Wendy's figured out how to do that in
Denver,
like that's what Wendy who owns the
comedy works.
She's figured out,
she's created a scene like that.
That scene is almost primarily
responsible or she's almost primarily
responsible or or or as one individual
for that entire comedy scene.
Yeah,
she's amazing.
Well she's called.
I give her credit because I think she's
cultivated such good talent that that
again,
that's kind of what you were saying
about Houston.
Like everyone that I know that I met
there,
that's from there.
It comes out of there is,
is a fucking phenomenal comedian.
Right?
Like they're like they're locals are
professionals here.
To this day when I do comedy,
like a do theaters,
they're like,
I'll do this.
The Belko,
it's like 5,000 seats.
I go through her,
I do it through her and I,
she also do her club,
so I always hang out with her when I'm
in town.
Like that lady's super important.
Yeah.
Like I did my special there in 2014 my
comedy central special because I like,
it was important to me to do it at that
club.
That club was one of the reasons why I
moved to Colorado for a brief time.
I was like,
this,
I'll be close to this club.
It was like I can,
I can survive here.
Like I need a pay station.
I need a base station to fuck around and
workout material.
I could use this place like everybody
else is doing it.
Like I could,
I could.
This could be a,
this is a real comedy community.
It really is.
Yeah.
There's a few like that that are
building so strong right now.
I think my only fear for the future is
there's a lot of new clubs that pop up
and a lot of clubs that have gone so
corporatized that they're all the same.
Then I'm still a club guy.
So for me,
I don't get to play theaters,
you know?
So when you do clubs,
you're,
you know,
at the mercy of the club system of
whatever that may be,
you know,
and a lot of them are,
a lot of them are so corporately
systematic.
I mean,
you feel like,
you're like,
sometimes you feel like,
you know the old joke of a musician
psych,
what's up Omaha?
And they're like,
what?
This is no Mas Missouri?
And you're like,
well,
it all feels the same.
Like some of the clubs feel the same.
That's true with a lot of the Improv's.
But what they've done is they figured
out a way to make it a very professional
experience.
Everywhere you go all over the country.
Yeah.
Like I accept what they're doing because
what they're doing is like a blend of
the art and commerce.
They've done a smart thing,
but they don't fuck with your act.
No.
As long as they don't fuck with my act,
I'm cool.
And it's all,
it was their professional and friendly.
I'm cool.
But there's a big difference between
working for them and like working for
[inaudible] in Nashville.
It's like owned by,
you know,
guys have owned it for a long time.
It's a super sweet club,
you know,
it just great guys.
It's just,
and it's a perfect old school.
You know,
it's an old school comedy club because
you walk around and look at the headshot
to go,
is he,
he's dead now.
He killed himself.
Then he died.
How many dead people that are at a lot,
man,
a lot.
That's like the comedy store is like a
posture Miss Hallway when he walked into
his,
everybody on the world is dead.
It's true.
Roseanne might be the only big picture
in the hallway that's still alive.
Well,
there's one wall when you get out of the
kitchen and you go towards the main
road.
If you took a right,
yeah,
that one wall three out of the four
people are dead.
Yeah.
That's what I mean.
Like it's like Rosangela one.
That's a lie.
That's on that side of the wall,
I think.
No,
I think it's Louie Anderson.
Oh yeah,
you're right.
No,
You're right.
You're only Anderson's alive.
Robin Williams is dead.
Surely.
Hemphill's dead.
Yup.
Um,
Richard Pryor's dead and Garry
shandling's death.
Shandling's Acessa shitty one.
I,
I'm held that she,
she has a big picture.
Is She on the wall?
I think she's not a big picture as a
smaller,
smaller on the wall.
Yeah,
there's a lot of them,
dude.
Yeah,
it's wild.
Yeah.
Early last Craig motherfucking Mac
today.
All right.
P Craig Mac flavor.
New Year.
You were the best.
Um,
where you get it.
Where are you going to next?
I'm finishing up shooting the second
season of,
I'm dying up here for showtime,
so I'm here in town doing that once it
started here.
Are you happy with it?
Everything's going well.
Smooth.
We added Brad Garrett who's on and who's
crazy.
Bread's good dude.
He's great.
Such a cool guy.
He's a great guy.
He's got the Best Club in Vegas.
Yeah.
And you know what's so funny,
man,
it's great to sit down and talk,
talking stories about,
stand up with him cause he's been around
for so long.
He knows.
I mean,
he's got such good gold of stuff I can't
talk about.
It's like I,
I want him to tell him like,
I don't want to tell any histories.
But she was a guy.
Craziest voice.
A real voice.
Very deep.
But he a great guy.
Awesome dude.
We,
they added him and they added this,
a young actress.
Xhosa.
Rockmore who fucking fuck her.
I'm just kidding.
I don't even know who that is.
She's Black Joe.
Is that why?
Cause she's black.
I wouldn't have said it.
No.
Yeah.
So we come out may six.
So now I'm shooting in town.
Next weekend I'm gonna go with you.
We're going to fuck around factory or
excuse me,
the Ice House.
Nice House.
There's so many clubs.
Uh,
yeah,
we're doing the ICEHOUSE Stena next
Friday and Saturday.
It's all sold out.
Fuckers.
Sorry.
But otherwise when I get back on the
road at the end of May to the first
dates,
I'll be doing a,
I go back up to,
I go up to Alberta while we were talking
about,
I go to Edmonton,
so I'll be in Edmonton the end of May.
So look on net Edmondton calendar.
I'll be up there.
Uh,
you do in that comedy club up there.
I'm doing house accommodate.
That place is great.
Yeah,
it's fun.
That's great family.
That's a,
that's an all time
great club.
It's really,
really fun.
Yeah.
And the family that runs it,
they're,
they're the Bronson's are great.
They're good to me.
So I love them now and raves about that
place.
Yeah,
I know.
They love him.
They love him and,
and,
and they,
they like,
they like a lot of store guys.
It's just by coincidence.
Like Bobby,
they love a lot of funny comics.
They're like funny people.
Triple.
He did his cd there.
Yeah.
Recorded there.
That's a great spot.
Don.
My rarer raves about that.
Brad Garret Club at the MGM.
Oh yeah.
It's like,
it's the best club we own.
Dom Dom is on,
I'm dying up here and this actually
happened this last week.
Uh,
dom had a scene in the show where he
like has a heart attack and uh,
you know,
he gets on a plane to go to Jersey or
something.
He flans there's like six missed phone
calls from Mark Marin and mark leaves
and voicemails being like,
hey man,
I heard something happened on set.
Cause you know,
like the game of telephone got out that
it was like someone said,
yeah,
that was done in a senior.
He had a heart attack.
So it was like,
wait,
what?
Tom had a one on it and it just bled out
into the ether,
you know,
so,
so dom called me,
he's like,
Hey Andrew,
I got to tell you people think I'm dead.
Did you who told people that I died on
set?
And I'm like,
I don't know man.
Maybe it'll give you some traction.
So let it keep going.
Keep subtraction.
Isn't that funny?
Maybe it'll go viral.
Fuck it.
You never know bro.
Dot.
Viral.
But Dom is the best man we've had.
He's awesome.
He's the best.
We've had some good comics pop up.
We're going to keep there.
They keep getting more cow.
Andy kindler came on the show.
Um,
fucking Rick Overton is back on the
show.
There's like a lot of great,
a lot of great people.
I became friends with dom cause we,
we hung out in a pool hall once.
Okay.
Yeah,
we did a Gig together,
but I didn't really know him.
And then I went to Amsterdam billiards
in New York and like
90 somewhere in the 90s and a,
I used to play a lot of pool and I was
there and Dama rare was there with his
own stick.
I was like,
what do you play pool?
He's like,
yeah,
he's pretty good.
I was like,
Shit,
let's play some pool.
And we played pool.
It's like,
I can't believe I fucking love him.
Play some real pool.
That's from Philadelphia.
From Philadelphia.
You've gotta be able to take a punch to
tell a joke and play some pool.
That's it.
You have to have the end know where the
good cheese sticks are.
Right,
right,
right.
Do you think that's Philadelphia people
like enough with the fucking chase day?
No,
they love it.
It's part of their fucking culture.
But you don't think they're annoyed
like,
oh,
you're saying that.
That's all we have.
And partially it is.
What are their food is coming out of
there?
Is anybody else being like,
dude,
you know what else is good out of
Philly?
Very good Italian food.
They have been as good at,
that's like Boston,
good Italian food,
New York.
I think Boston has some of the best of
talent.
If we go to the north end,
that's not true.
Oh yeah.
I have good Italian food that you can't
fuck with New York.
I grew up there.
Trust me.
One of the same New York,
Boston to me.
No,
you don't think he could fuck with it.
Sorry.
Boston.
Like I love Ya.
I love Ya.
But I think there's a smaller amount of
good places.
Whereas New York,
there's an endless supply per capita.
It's fucking yes.
Supply of flour on the floor and fucking
people with aprons and making sure,
oh fucking sauce.
My own shot shade shed.
It's just,
uh,
I feel like there's a larger
concentration of guineas in like the New
York,
New Jersey area.
And in Boston it was more of a
concentration of Irish.
There was more Irish,
Irish.
Yeah,
I was just a few Italian,
but they were heavily out numbers like
East Boston,
you know,
like a few places,
little Italy,
few places where I feel comfortable with
it because I'm an orange guy.
When I go to Boston,
people think I'm more than just slipped
right in.
They assume I'm there.
Well,
what are you,
Irish and Italian who was,
hey,
you're one of theirs.
Yeah,
but not one of their Sam Tino.
They hear Santina Santina they get mad.
What?
We'll try to this.
Yeah.
When I first moved to Boston,
I had an Irish last name,
the opposite,
but I'm mostly Italian.
I'm three quarters Italian where you
look it.
So it's like,
uh,
like,
Whoa,
wait,
you got fucking Irish last name and
you're almost all Italian.
Fucking shame.
Fuck it.
Fuck that.
Shame.
There's some real Irish versus Italian
animosity in Boston and like the in most
cities,
late seventies early eighties when I
first moved there,
I was going to say like the history of
Irish and Italian.
They didn't fuck,
they didn't really get along too well.
I did not think I moved there in,
it must've been like 79 79 and then I
went to high school there in 81 that was
my first year in high school.
Where were you born?
I was born in New Jersey.
I was gonna say I thought Jersey,
but we lived in California for a while.
I lived in California from age seven to
11 and then we lived in Florida for a
little bit and then we lived in Boston
and Jamaica plain for a year and a half,
two years,
somewhere in there.
And then we moved to Newton,
which is a very nice suburb.
Upper falls for a nice,
I was fancy.
It's very quiet.
There's a lot of big lawns.
Everybody's relaxed fences.
People born out of their fucking mind.
Can't wait to escape,
you know,
it's one of those places.
Don't realize how good they have it.
Well,
that's what happens.
I went back recently,
I drove through the streets.
I'm like,
Jack could live here.
It's fucking places.
Great.
Well,
you have a new perspective.
When you get older,
when you're younger,
you're like,
get the fuck out of the shade hole.
Well,
when you're younger,
you just so filled with angst.
He just like,
you have no idea.
Like think about this.
When you were 17 you had no idea you're
going to be a professional comic.
No idea.
Things going to work out.
You're going to be on a TV series,
going to be having a good time.
He had no idea.
So he just like,
Whoa,
what if it doesn't?
What if it all goes wrong?
You see all these people around you and
this guy's always drunk and he's doing
coke.
I got,
he thought,
fuck Outta here.
I gotta get the fuck out of this town.
The fuck away from these people.
And then you go back when you're an
adult and you go,
this is a great place.
I grew up in a really nice town.
It was probably only because when you
leave it's nice to come back.
Oh,
I didn't have anybody telling me it was
awesome.
Five,
like a smart older brother.
They'd be like,
Dude,
look,
here's the Catholic school.
Girls are all horny.
They're all right there.
They just wait outside in front of the
school.
I would have had strategies,
dude.
There was no one that was hornier than
the girls who went to Catholic school.
No one.
Yeah,
they separated those girls from boys and
they were a different animal than the
girls I went to school with freaks.
Yeah.
I went to public school.
I went to Newton South and uh,
when we were in high school we would get
out and we would meet girls that were
coming off of the Catholic girls school.
These girls would go after guys.
They weren't like regular girls.
Like it's hunger games.
Predator.
Like they were starving.
They needed water.
Dick,
it was crazy.
The horniest girl I ever dated when I
was young,
went to,
was in an all girl Catholic school.
She was a great gal who was a fuck
machine cause she was like made a joke
about her that like you could,
you could roll a dick passed her like a
kitten with a ball of yarn and she would
just,
she couldn't help it.
She wasn't a bad person,
but she was always horny and it took me
years to figure out what was going on.
It was something that I really
considered in a very strange way.
Okay.
I had a,
I,
it really puzzled me because I had these
preconceived notions about how women
behave,
but these Catholic school girls through
a giant monkey wrench into this notion
like,
okay,
that makes sense for the regular girls.
Regular girls,
they might let you know.
They think you're cute.
He seems nice.
You,
you ask around,
you ask a friend to ask her if she likes
me.
And you know,
there was like this little thing,
those Catholic girls,
they would cut to the chase.
They were like werewolves.
They would just charge to the room and
grab a guy,
hey,
how are you want to make out?
Next thing you know,
you're fingering them.
They were crazy.
It was,
there were a totally different animal,
your hand and putting it down their
pants and girls didn't like it.
Other girls,
the regular girls did not like,
they were like gang members.
They're like gang members.
They all had their own uniform.
They come over with their fucking plaid
skirts on and just fuck everything.
Like the Tasmanian Devil.
They would just tornado fucking the
whole of the school and they prayed on
these boys because they didn't have any,
they had no boys.
They're in a whole school.
The hundreds of girls when you were
oppressed,
that that's what you get,
dude,
that is not good.
When you take away human emotion like
that,
you're fucked.
All they're doing is just all day math,
science,
Spanish,
Dik,
dik,
dik dik dik dik dik just run it to the
ticker tape of Dixon.
Just going through their head and Tj's
and boners.
It's Squirt,
squirt,
squirt.
Just thinking about so on,
sucking her titties and eating their
box.
That's all they're thinking about.
That's all they thought about.
I mean,
I really like for that.
For years.
That girl fucked me up because I had all
these ideas about like a spectrum of
natural female sexuality,
like this girl's Hornier than that girl,
but this girl was wanting to do than
that girl,
and she really likes this,
but she really likes that.
But most of them,
they act like girls.
You've got to let them know that not
this bitch off the charts rabid.
She was rabid,
rabid.
They suppress the shit out of her.
They just left her in this fucking
thing.
It was crazy.
Meanwhile,
her sisters was really weird.
Her sister didn't go to Catholic school.
Her sister went to school with me.
Should we do a regular school?
She was normal.
She was fucking normal.
I mean,
she was a,
just nice girl and everything.
Nothing wrong with her.
Fun hang out with,
but normal.
She wasn't a werewolf.
Yeah,
nothing insane.
Her sister was a werewolf.
The Werewolf for Dick too.
She was a monster and it was the only
one in the family that was like that.
And I just don't,
I don't see any other correlation shiny
this for years.
She's probably in a fucking orgy.
She's a fifth nine nine 80 getting stuck
by like five [inaudible].
Two of them.
She's German.
She's face fucking him there.
That she's an animal.
Girls an animal.
Is He?
I said,
well that's I gotta be with are a women
that get into porn.
Probably had some kind of repression
like that.
Right?
That's the thing.
It's more molestation.
Yes,
the most.
It's the most,
but it's not all of them.
I,
you know,
there's a thing that they always want to
say that all women who get into porn or
fucked up,
man,
I,
I know,
I don't believe that.
No.
Yeah.
And there's a thing that people was
like,
someone was saying the other day that
porn addiction is real and porn is
fucked up.
Cause it ruins way guys think.
And like maybe some guys.
But isn't that the same as with
gambling?
Like isn't gambling really bad for some
guys?
Yeah.
You know it is right?
It ruins people's lives.
Ruins their life.
Yes.
I think there's certain guys that just
can't fucking gamble.
Right.
Who was it that was saying that he,
his dad lost their house over gambling
early podcast.
God dammit,
that growing up.
Want to say it was one of Calvin's
friends,
was it Jimmy Burke?
It might've been,
I mean,
I come from my grandfather's a
microphone that works at the dog track
in Chicago.
I think it was Jimmy Burke chose whole
life.
Dad was a crazy gambler.
But yeah man,
there's a,
I knew a lot of guys like that from the
pool hall that had just every nickel
they earned,
they would below.
They always owed money and they were
hiding from people is always gambling
that lifestyle.
So wild.
But I don't have a problem with
gambling.
So if I go to Vegas and uh,
you know,
I don't bet on anything,
but if I,
I used to bet on fights,
so if I,
maybe if I'm in Vegas and just for a
fucking goof,
Canelo Alvarez is going to fight.
Gennady Golovkin I get to the sport to
book like a day before the fight and my
cow put a fucking couple hundred bucks
on this.
I think triple g's got it.
And A,
and I'll throw my hat in the ring,
but I'm not going to lose my mind and
bet my life was with some people.
It's their whole existence to have to,
it doesn't mean that I shouldn't be able
to go gamble.
It's just like the same thing is if I'm
in a hotel room and I want to jerk off,
I don't want to hear your bullshit about
somebody who's addicted to and it ruins
their life.
That's,
I'm sad.
I'm sad that someone got addicted to it
and [inaudible] them,
but as nothing that I can do about that
in porn is a real thing.
So what do you,
what do you want me to do?
It was the same with alcohol is to
abandoned all my jerking off and not
watch the stuff that I want to watch
because somewhere there's someone who
can't handle it.
Or do we have to like educate people?
Hey,
some people they have weak chins and
they just,
they don't think,
well,
you shouldn't get into boxing.
Right.
Okay.
It says,
you know what I mean?
Like if you can't take a punch,
don't get into boxing.
If you just,
if you watch one porn film and next
thing you know,
five hours later you're dehydrated.
You know you haven't left the room,
your legs don't work.
Your fucking hands tired.
You got tennis elbow like it's not my
fault.
Okay.
I don't know what to tell you should I
not jerk off now?
But those people that suffer through,
it's like people were alcoholics like,
oh,
what are you drinking?
You're drinking?
Yeah.
I like to have a drink.
You know why?
Cause I'll go weeks without having one
for it ruined my family doesn't fuck my
life up.
I like to have a drink.
I don't go home and kick my fucking dog
around the house and beat my kids.
I like to have a drink.
Is that all right?
To have a glass of wine with dinner?
Does that mean that I have to respect
the guy who lost everything and he's
fucking homeless and he's sucking dicks
for cheap wine?
Nope,
because he couldn't handle it.
So I should add of respect for him.
Pushed that peanut on the wireless side.
No,
no,
no.
It's not a palate cleanser.
When you're having a nice steak and some
a fine garlic mashed potatoes,
that's a terrible drug that ruins
families.
Right?
Just like the porn.
Just like fucking everything though.
It's like working out.
You can be addicted to working out so
many people are.
They are.
There's a lot of people that are off.
Stop you from lifting.
Come on,
come on.
People are too fucking Goddamn soft.
That's the problem.
We're so saw other people so much that
we're ruining them and we're ruining
them.
We were ruining people.
God dammit.
Santina know.
How did we get to this?
Maybe it doesn't know.
He's looking at porn like he mad.
He does.
He looks at porn all the time.
I see it in his eyes like you see the
glint glimmer,
what was going on?
Let me see what's going on.
Yeah.
Watching porn is one of the weirdest
taboos because you think about how many
people watch it.
I mean it is.
I the last that didn't we talk about
this once,
but it was something insane.
Like 20% of all Internet
traffic is all one word.
I thought it was more than that.
More when you asserting 39% I'm gonna
say 39 I'm going to say,
I'd say I'm going to do 42 isn't most of
it Netflix now?
30% 30% what percent is Netflix?
70 I want to say 49 I don't know why I'm
in the ninth today.
I'm going to say 36 Ooh,
this is like a,
the price is right.
You got 37 yelled it.
Damn some knuckles stupid.
Went to five and just North America,
but 36 of all.
Wow.
Do you got super specific?
Wait,
wait,
32.25 in just North America.
36 overall.
So,
but that was October 8th of 2015 so it's
got to be more now probably been,
how crazy is that?
That the United States has that big of a
market and the rest of the world is just
four or five points.
I'll tell you why that's wrong because
uh,
Ian Edwards was just somewhere that was
saying how the international market now
has almost matched and Ian's working on
a Netflix show and their international
markets almost mashed in North America.
Now.
That was what,
three years ago?
It's got to be way higher now.
That's crazy.
Way Higher.
That is crazy.
You know they made in the,
in the fourth quarter last year,
Netflix,
take a guests,
don't look it up and take a guess.
80 kazillion dollars.
No,
no,
no.
And just the fourth quarter last year
they made 3.4 billion and just the
fourth court.
10 for the year.
That's probably right.
Wow.
Well death thrown it around at comics.
I'll tell you that.
I wish they were thrown into me.
They will be santeen and first of all,
you would have been a little too white
and the future is dark.
I know the future's Brown and Meek.
If you had glasses and you were thin and
Brown,
you'd have a show.
I'd have two shows.
If you were a woman and you had glasses.
Yeah.
And you were Brown.
I might,
I might transform.
No,
I think that what it is right now is
that they just have so many specialists
that they're working on.
That's my biggest problem was trying to
say that they be like,
oh,
you know,
they're only going after,
I forget what term he used,
like either hipsters or they're going
after a,
you know,
diversity and like they're not,
they're not going to give it to a white
guy.
I'm like,
John Malaney just got a special,
yeah,
we talking about like this,
Craig Ferguson just got it special.
It's just those that have built it.
You have to build yourself.
You have to be built.
Well,
that's how it always was.
Yeah,
of course
the way it always used to be,
and this is the problem is there's no
real valid entry level show.
So what it used to be is you would get
on like young comedian special on hbo
and then there would be like four of Ya.
Everybody would do 15 minutes or so and
then that's how you'd make it.
Right.
And then there was the Rodney
dangerfield specials and that's how we
found out about Lenny Clarke and dom
Irrera,
right.
Bill Hicks,
Sam Kinison,
dice clay,
they all came out of the Rodney
dangerfield specials.
There's not a thing like that anymore.
So you got to go through those things
before he got a special,
it's wild.
Now it's like you just kinda get
specials,
right.
You have to find a way into the game.
You have to find,
you have to find like the niche that
gets you to the place to get the
special.
Will you have a showtime special?
I do hepatis special up on showtime last
year,
but the problem is showtimes market is
so,
you know,
so specific.
It's only people that subscribed.
Meanwhile,
Netflix is fucking everybody.
That's true.
But meanwhile Sebastian became of the
biggest comics in the world because it's
just cause a showtime.
Yeah,
no,
Sebastian is the Unicorn man.
Like when people go,
well,
how did he make it so big?
Well first of all,
he's really funny,
very funny,
great guy,
family friendly and for whatever reason
he,
whatever show times fucking target
market is clear.
He just flew right through it.
He was like,
there's an opening and he just like,
oh shit,
I'll touching the wall.
He just went right through.
Right.
It's perfect.
Perfect.
Yeah,
but that's what all that is.
That's all perfect timing and I,
you know,
yeah,
I mean showtimes bigger.
I don't know if I would do another one
anytime soon at all,
but if they did,
if I did do another one,
I do it with them.
You know,
I don't really care where it is.
I,
I just care the content that I put on it
and someone see it online,
can they go and get that show time?
That's the biggest,
that's the problem.
See,
that's the thing about Netflix that's so
great is everybody has it,
but showtime is like my specialist
always there.
It's just you have to have showtime.
We've
talked about doing this with podcasts
about doing the same kind of thing,
like coming up with a bunch of cash and
have an all podcasts under one umbrella.
Right.
You know,
w like a Netflix type deal because
everybody has their own way of doing it
now.
Like everybody has their own way of
doing it in terms of like,
some people have ads,
some people have like a go fund me or
Patrion page.
But that would fuck,
yeah.
Would fuck you up,
right?
Probably.
Yeah.
I mean that would,
that seems like,
unless it was like a netflix thing where
everybody had it.
It's,
that would have to be the thing.
Yeah.
But what do you like Netflix is movies
and movies.
Take a shit load of money to make
Netflix is TV shows.
They take a shitload of money to make
this podcast.
You could have done it on a phone.
We could have set our iphone on the
table right there.
Press the auto record thing and just
gone.
Yeah.
But instead we've got Jamie doing all
these fake button pushing and pr bro and
fun flat cap.
Apple's market cap.
That's why me and Marcus Brown market
cap is closing in on $1 trillion.
He had got $1 trillion.
You could literally buy every single
NFL,
NBA and mls team for NASA and a hundred
thousand teslas and still have money
leftover.
But you couldn't buy apple.
Whoa.
Uh,
by Netflix seven and a half times.
Wow.
But apple is that what they're doing
with podcasts is very interesting
because they just,
they're just an aggregator.
You know,
like you have to have your own host and
you just put it up on there and,
but through their itunes,
I mean we're always in this trending
section and we're always in like,
um,
like the rankings when you're looking at
like who the top podcasts are,
we're always in there and that helps
people find you totally.
So they're helping people find you.
They are kind of a network in a way,
but they're not a network in a way.
Like they're not like a youtube where
they control content and not like
they're not,
they're not really,
they're not hosting you.
Well they have apple music too,
but podcasts are part of that.
I wonder if they,
to do that so weird that they don't
merge those like that that podcast is a
separate tab,
which makes no fucking sense to me.
Like it's just to be a sub category of
music.
It should be.
Right.
But then there's a thing of if you have
something on itunes,
right,
and like apple music,
is it totally different jam,
right.
Like apple music is them hosting it,
isn't it?
They would have.
It would have your podcast.
So if you said something really fucked
up,
like maybe they would get in trouble for
having you on.
I don't think so.
Think they won't sponsor someone song.
No.
Yeah,
same way.
Same thing.
Like any like radical punk rock fucking
crazy to my fucking mother host it.
Right.
Going into it.
But I mean I don't think but like look
up like,
but apple music can't like what does a
spotify market versus the apple music
market?
Like?
I don't think apple music has does well
at all.
I think she's doing way better now,
but not as well as spotify does.
Cause I feel like spotify just dominates
the mark.
Yeah.
But see,
apple music's on everyone's phone now
and you just find it and use it.
It's so easy to use.
You don't use spotify.
See,
but I think it's the,
the youngest generation loves spotify.
Like they love soundcloud.
Soundcloud.
Yeah.
So big.
They loved they soundcloud.
A lot of people were using the host
podcasts.
Yeah,
totally.
But a lot of people think that it won't
be around.
Oh,
I think that's the opposite.
Yeah.
Not only do I think,
not only is it for stuff like that,
that's homemade podcast stuff like diy,
it's also set to surpass spotify page
paid subscribers.
Right,
right.
Cause spotify starts off for free.
Right,
right.
Interesting.
Um,
but like that's my thing is like,
uh,
you know,
like that the future of soundcloud thing
like that is because it's,
it's all,
everybody loves diy shit.
Whether it's musicians or like all those
musicians and artists now that are on
spotify,
it's all people like making music in
their fucking,
in their house.
Fucking youtube,
you know?
I mean,
how many youtube millionaires have been
made from a lot,
so many weird shit.
Putting up videos,
talking.
I know some from the,
I know some from the beginning,
like I used to do a youtube sketch thing
a long time ago and like caught fire a
little bit on a fairly small scale and
the people that we kind of associated
with when it was starting to grow,
two or three of them now that I know
have made so much money from that and
they were just from the jump,
they were kind of like in right as the
cusp was like beginning.
You know what happens with that dude who
got in trouble with the suicide?
Is that Jager?
Logan Paul.
Which one is he?
Logan.
Paul Logan.
Paul.
He's,
he's banned.
They don't,
they demonetize his entire channel and I
thought he's still making videos.
Right?
He's not making any money.
They took all his ad money away because
he electrocuted a dead rat.
No.
Yes.
He did a video yesterday at two and a
half.
A million views.
So,
but he doesn't get paid?
No,
there were saying that it's,
his entire channel was demonetized
unless he got lawyers involved.
So then he could be just using his
channel and then getting sponsored
videos
and merge,
which is one of the big things to me,
it's stunning.
Makes more unmerge probably then it
doesn't from fucking youtube probably
does it.
To me it's stunning that there is not a
competitor to Youtube,
not a real competitor.
Yeah,
there's been tried.
They've tried.
It's crazy.
Vimeo is just not,
not happening.
Well it's a video hosting site,
but it's not,
it's not as user friendly.
Well it's also,
it doesn't suggest things.
Their algorithm that youtube was totaled
out to having what's next on the right
hand side,
it's like so attractive because there's
always something there to click on Vimeo
does.is that they're not as
sophisticated in that way.
They want to be the artistic,
uh,
you know,
culture.
They want to cultivate like the sexy
little artistic thing.
Youtube is like,
fuck it.
Here's everything we've,
you've ever wanted to see.
And ads for Tampons,
we had,
um,
W W we're putting up every video on
Vimeo as well as on Youtube,
but on youtube it'll have over a million
videos,
a million hits.
And then you go to Vimeo and the same
video we'll have like what,
20,
30,000,
20,000.
Yeah,
that's,
I was gonna say,
cause there,
there was so sick,
their viewer traffic is so much lower.
It's so much lower.
The only time I watch vimeo is when
someone sends me an email link.
And you got to think that video link is
being sent to whatever million people I
have on twitter.
Totally.
I have like 2 million people in 2
million Russian bots.
I'm not sure which one.
They're all bought suits.
I don't,
I don't know how that works.
I think in a bought,
some of them they say it's if you
haven't used it to post,
but there's a lot of people that use
twitter and they don't post.
So like how do you know if someone's a
Bot,
like there's some suspicion of their,
um,
their detection methods to decide who's,
he always can tell when you look at
their fucking profile,
the stuff they write is so funny.
Oh,
there's definitely some of those,
you know,
I get a lot of those on instagram.
Get a lot of those really.
Yay.
A weird like fake comments.
You know,
like a,
I learned how to make $109 a week all
over the place.
Those things are everywhere,
you know,
it's uh,
it's like,
who are they getting with that?
Like,
who are they?
Who are they going after?
Literally nobody.
Yeah.
Nobody,
they can't make any money.
That's gotta be just like a whole soul
people.
They'll get some man.
Really,
man,
I watched the saddest show once with
this old dude kept getting,
he kept getting scammed by this Nigerian
scammer who's pretended he was a hot
girl that wanted to meet him in Europe.
This poor fuck flew to Europe twice to
meet this girl.
And both times she came up with excuses
why she couldn't meet him,
but for some,
but,
but you know,
like dude,
Darwinism dude.
Well,
yeah,
I think has shown an idiot.
Can you feel bad for that guy?
He was this older guy and his,
his daughter and uh,
everybody died and no,
they were alive,
but they were sad.
They were watching this poor guy get
fucking scammed and keep traveling to
Europe,
and he didn't want to believe the girl
didn't exist and you were watching it
and like everyone knew,
but him like you knew I watched him
like,
no,
that's why I can't feel bad.
Did that God let him live that fantasy.
Then life is just a fantasy.
It's fantasy.
Let him live that sad fantasy.
Al De Nova.
Tada.
I watched the video that the other day.
We're at the store,
uh,
we were in the secret comic bar.
We started talking about Aldo Nova.
I'm like,
do you remember that song?
And I put it up on Youtube.
We're sitting there like laughing,
watching some video.
Yeah.
I miss the old videos,
man.
The beginning of it.
Nova uses guitar to break into a
building and then he performs on stage.
This is the beginning of it.
You could play at the beginning of it
because it's not music.
No,
no.
We can't.
We'll get booted off youtube,
but it's a fucking ridiculous music
videos.
A bunch of dudes and machine guns.
They opened up this helicopter lands and
fucking Aldo Nova steps out.
He's got a leopard outfit,
is sleeves are rolled up.
He's got knee high boots on and he
doesn't make eye contact with anybody.
Walks to the fucking state.
You can see your eyes back to the door.
It looks he's got a purpose in his walk.
They get to the door,
but he can't get in because the door is
locked.
Shit to trying to get in.
Fuck can't get in.
Step back.
I'll though says he tries to break it
with his gun,
but he's weak ass bitch,
bitch.
That's where it seems almost like qb.
The guitar music is the key.
Puts the strap on.
Check this out,
man.
Down.
How Dow
melts off the fucking lock with his
guitar.
Bitch kicks open the door.
The fucking smoke machine starts going.
They all walk in and the bands already
ready.
Come on baby.
Yeah,
that was it.
This is a timestamp.
This is what happens when you take lsd
and marijuana out of the market.
As soon as you make it illegal really
bad and make these fucking people
terrified for their lives.
No one does drugs and everybody just
falls into this kind of shitty music.
It's that what they're doing,
man.
I don't know what they're doing.
They literally like children.
They like been separated from the
umbilical cord.
They don't know how to get nutrition.
They're flying around freaking the fuck
out.
What is this?
Where am I?
It's just a fantasy.
Can you let us time to sit?
Lie.
This is such a terrible song.
When I was in high school,
it was the shit,
man.
Everybody's backside.
That's a terrible fucking song.
Now you do.
Yeah,
but back then,
you know,
it's like def leppard.
Sing and pour some sugar on me.
Fantasy.
All right,
I gotta wrap this up.
Um,
Andrew Santinello tells these wonderful
people.
Are you going to be,
uh,
I'll be with you at the Ice House.
Shit.
Otherwise,
next weekend you fucks.
Otherwise a check me out.
Cheeto Santana on instagram and twitter.
Cheeto Santina always at the comedy
store as well.
Always at the comedy store's come.
Alright.
You fucks.
Thank you everybody.
Bye.
[inaudible] so fun.
Okay.